Oh, okay.
I just made it back just in time.
I literally like... I literally came out just to like to wash my... I got a new package yesterday.
And it's a new gamer subs cup.
So like, you know, what's the best thing?
Sorry.
He's being... He thinks I have food on me, but I don't.
I literally I just opened a gamer subs package.
Anyway, if you guys want 10% off your gamer subs, it is use the code DOUGHGAMER.
Kiki bird.
Anyway, I really need it.
I need some caffeine right now.
I'm so tired.
My sleep schedule is a fucking mess, by the way.
So when you're a gamer subs partner, it's not food.
It's literally a cup and some powder.
Anyway.
Anyway, I was pouring water, by the way.
So into my gamer subs cup.
Anyway, as I was saying, when you are a gamer subs partner, you get to have... you get sent free packages of... Look, he's... Okay, the reason why he's really angry right now is because he thinks I have food.
It's powder!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I... It's powder.
It's not food!
It's...
Bring me back to the bed.
You get free packages of newly released items.
So whenever they have... whenever they release like a new... like it's not waifu cups, but like just like new cups in general when it comes to like products they're doing and new like flavors or whatever.
They usually send me the... they send... I don't know if they do it for anybody else.
I think... I'm pretty sure they do it for everybody else, but they would send me free packages of all... like, you know.
Of like the newest products and stuff.
So...
So like yesterday I got it and I was like, oh, thank God.
I need some... I need some caffeine anyway.
I was like, oh, thank God.
I really needed caffeine.
So... so I'm just trying it out right now.
So, all right.
Story time.
Okay.
So the reason why I was... I had to be a little late is that I had a bed appointment today at like 3.20.
PM and then it ended.
I didn't realize this, but it was supposed to be a regular checkup, by the way.
It is supposed to be super regular checkup, like just to see if...
If the... he's on this like anti-scratching medication.
So like, we... I give it to him like one tablet a day and it like helps suppress his itchiness because of his allergies.
So... so like that's what I... so like...
I had to get refill on the prescription because today was like, I only have two pills left.
Two pills left.
So I had to get a refill today and it was just a regular checkup.
And I got there.
I got there.
Yeah.
And then we were doing our regular checkup and then the vet looked into his ear and was like, oh, my God.
And then...
it was like, there's a lot of discharge in there.
And I was like, huh?
I was like, oh no, is it because of that guy, and he's like, have you been cleaning the ear?
and I was like, oh, not since I moved, because I...
Usually my dad would do it.
And I was like that's since I moved.
And then I saw as like the worst of my fault.
And then...
So then...
And then she was like, okay, I'm gonna take him to the back and I'm gonna look into his ear and also like scrub his ears for a test.
So then she took him to the back and I was like, I'm pretty sure he got his ears cleaned when I took him to the groomer.
Which was one month ago.
So the last time he got his ears cleaned was a month ago.
And so then I was like, oh...
And then she came back and she was like, it's a mess.
And I was like, huh?
And she was like, she just opened the door and she was like, it's a mess.
And then she was like, yeah, like one ear is okay.
But the other ear, yeah.
And then I was like, oh no.
And she was like, yeah, there's like yeast and like a bacteria in one of the ear.
But the other ear is fine.
Like she still has yeast in there.
She still has like yeast in that ear, but like it's not that bad.
Like it's just, it's like a lot better than the other ear.
So, and it was, it's not infected.
And I was like, oh, and I was like, is it my fault?
I didn't clean his ears properly.
I didn't clean his ears for a month.
It's like my fault.
And she's like, no, no, it's not your fault actually.
And I was so fucking relieved.
Apparently it's because of his allergies.
He's like, she was like, no, no, because usually because he is allergic to everything in the fucking world.
She was like, because he's like really allergic to everything in the fucking world.
That like dogs with these types of allergies tend to get ear infections.
Incredibly easily, especially for like yeast and stuff.
And then I was like, oh, thank God.
Oh, thank fucking God.
And she was like, yeah, it's very common.
And I was like, oh, oh, not, I mean, not great for me because that means I have to pay more.
And like, I have to bring you back to the vet again.
And I was just like, oh, thank God.
But at least it wasn't my fault.
I was like...
Thank God.
At least it wasn't my fault.
But also, oh, fuck.
Like, that's more money I have to spend.
Like, that's more money I have to spend today.
And then so, so she was like, yeah, like, oh, I put too much water in my gamer subs cup.
And then she was like, yeah, so we're going to have, you're going to have to like, you're going to have to like, uh, uh, have to buy this medicine to clean your dog's ears for 10 days.
And that shit freaks me out because my dad used to do it.
And now that I live by myself, I have to do it.
So like, I'm a little freaked out about that because like I, because he had to stick this like medication thing into his ear and then squirt it and then like massage his ear.
And like, I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Because it has to be like in his ear canal too.
It has to be like in his fucking ear canal.
And then like, I gotta make sure he sits still.
And like, I have to be like, squeeze it in.
He's like, make sure to squeeze it good.
And then like massage his ears and everything.
Massage the backside of his ear and everything.
And I'm like, oh no.
Cause like I, the scary part is literally like sticking the thing in his ear, in his ear canal.
And that's like the scariest shit.
Yeah.
Anyway.
So, so yeah.
So it was like a 200.
So it was supposed to be a regular fast checkup.
And then it turned into like an hour and 30 minutes.
And I was like, no.
I was like, I was supposed to be.
It was supposed to be a fast.
By the way.
And I literally came here for a refill of my prescription.
But I think the vet forgot.
The vet forgot about it.
Because I, when I was like.
She was like, all right.
Is everything good?
I was like, yeah.
And then she's like, okay, you can pay up in the front.
So I went to the front.
I was like, she like gave me the ear medicine.
And I was like, oh, what about the refill on my prescription?
And then the reception lady was like, oh, you're not.
We didn't put that.
We don't have any left.
Like we didn't, we didn't like know that I was like your order.
And I was like, that was the whole point of this checkup.
That was literally the whole.
I can't just stop the medication.
He literally has to take one tablet every day for the rest of his life.
What do you mean?
You didn't know?
Like, what do you mean?
It's an everyday thing.
I can't just stop.
But like, basically, basically she's like, oh yeah.
Like we have to reorder the prescription.
Like we got, we have to, we have to reorder the prescription.
And y'all have to go back to the vet to like pick it up.
And I'm like, are you serious?
I was just like, are you serious?
What do you mean?
The point was literally to get a refill.
Anyway, so they're like, we're going to order it.
And then like the moment it comes in stock, you can come over and pick it up.
And I'm like, okay.
Like, I'm just like, okay.
I'm so sad because that means I have to pay for another appointment.
And like, I guess like, no, I have to pay for not, I could just grab the prescription.
But that means I have to pay for an Uber to get there and then Uber back.
Like I don't have to bring a dad along, but I still have to, I still have to Uber there.
I was so sad.
I was just like, what do you mean?
You don't have any, you have to ordering more.
I'm like, this was the reason I came to, I didn't go to the checkup for his fucking ears.
We discovered the ear problem on the checkup.
Like we discovered the ear problem on the checkup.
I literally just got here to check up on his, like, get the refill on the prescription and to see if it's like doing okay.
And the medication is working.
Cause it's working.
Cause it was my first time using that medication.
Um, because like, um, I'm pretty sure it's a new thing.
Like the tablet thing, because like a couple of years ago, um, the tablet thing didn't exist.
It was usually just shots.
Uh, you get a shot or whatever, but like tablet thing is new and it's less like, like you don't have to do like needles and everything.
Um, and like now, so like, this was the first time of me trying the medication with like one tablet a day and it was working.
It actually is working.
His hair is starting to grow back, which is fucking crazy.
I've never seen hair on his ears before, but like it's starting to, it's starting to grow back.
Like I was like, oh my God, it's not fully white now.
I can't, it's not just skin.
I literally see like strands of hair on his ears.
Like, no, he's still bald.
But like, you know, like when a balding person has like a little bit of hair, like he's still bald, but like you can see like some strands of hair, which is good.
So like that was a whole point of the visit.
But like in the end, like it's okay.
It fucked me over.
Cause they're like, yeah, like we didn't have like, I don't understand.
I don't understand.
Go
back.
Okay.
Anyway, anyway, um, now I have to deal with his ears too.
So like he has a lot of, he has, he's a genetic freak, but like I've accepted it since he was, since he turned one year.
So I, for like one year, he was a normal dog.
He was literally a normal fucking dog for one entire year.
And then after that year was over.
He, his allergies developed and I fucking live with it since.
Like I've accepted, I've accepted his face.
Anyway, um, anyway, um, what was I gonna say?
Oh yeah.
Um, yesterday was very depressing for dad because, um, I took him to the dog park.
And, um.
I took him, uh, uh, to the dog park and, um, there was no small dogs.
Uh, there were no small dogs at the park.
And, uh, I was very sad because, um, I was like, oh no, I, all I wanted to do was interact.
It was him to interact with other dogs.
Like that was the reason why I took him to the dog park.
And so, so it was very sad.
It was so sad.
I felt really bad because he was a loner like me.
So, so it, it was just big dogs coming in and, but I couldn't put him to the big dog park because he's way too small for the big dog park.
And I was really scared that big dog was gonna come over there and knock him down because that happened last time.
And so, so, so I, I literally was like, okay, I'm gonna wait for an hour.
I didn't bring a ball this time.
The one day I didn't bring a ball because I was really worried that like he was gonna get bullied for his ball again.
And I didn't want to deal with that today, yesterday.
So I was like, okay, I'm not gonna bring a ball.
There has to be other dogs here because there were other dogs.
So there was, I didn't bring a ball this time.
The one time I didn't bring a ball because I didn't want him to get bullied.
Um, because other dogs would steal his ball.
So like, that's why I didn't bring it.
And then he would get really upset about it and start like harassing the owners and be like, make your dog behave.
I didn't want him to also harass the owners.
Cause like last time he would like, he would walk up to the owners and like harass them for their, for his ball.
And he was like, give me my ball back.
Oh, I didn't tell the story in the public stream.
Sorry, I told the story in the member stream, but he literally, the other dogs would steal his ball.
And then he would bark at them and they wouldn't give the ball back.
So instead of like barking at them even more, he literally figured out who was this dog's owner.
Walked up to the dog's owner.
And started barking at them and demanding them to teach that dog a lesson and give back his ball.
And like...
And so I didn't want to do that again.
I didn't want to deal with that again.
So, so I was like, okay.
So if you guys want to see pictures of it, it's in the member stream.
I don't remember what stream was it again guys.
It's in the member stream.
In one of the member stream.
I don't remember which one, but like I showed a picture of it, of what it looks like.
It's so fucking funny.
Anyway, yeah, he knows how to call the manager.
Like he's a fucking Karen.
So I didn't want to deal with that.
And so I was like, okay, I'm not gonna bring a ball.
I don't, I'm not, I'm not going to bring a ball this time.
And so it was so sad because no small dog came to the small dog park.
It was an hour.
I waited an hour and there was no small dog.
I was so sad.
And then the saddest part was that he looks cause it's a fence.
It's fenced up.
So like he could see the other big dogs having fun.
So he would like, he's just walking up to the fence.
And like, he's looking at them.
Like he's just looking across the fence.
It was just like...
I kept barking.
Cause he's like, nah, that'd be it.
And then he would like, he would walk up cause there's owners sitting at like against the fence.
The owners of the big dogs are sitting against the fence.
And we would walk up to the lady.
I think the thing that he really wanted to do was...
The ladies.
So there were ladies against the fence.
You know, with the ladies of the big dog owners against the fence.
So he kept like walking to the ladies and was like barking at the ladies for pets and stuff.
But the ladies couldn't pet him because there's a fence.
So they would, he would like stick, they would stick their hands out.
And then dad would just be like sniffing them and barking.
Like, pay attention to me.
And I'm like, please, please.
Please, I'm sorry.
I'll stay for another.
I was like, I'm gonna stay for 20 more minutes.
And if there's no small dog, we're leaving.
So I stayed at the dog park for an entire hour.
And literally I felt so bad.
I was like, I'm sorry.
You can't make any friends today.
And yet to see the other dogs have fun.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean to.
I thought there would be some other dogs.
The craziest part was that people were bringing in more dogs.
But they were all big dogs.
It was so fucked up.
I was like, what happened to the small dog economy?
Like, I was like, what happened to the small dog economy?
Why is it all big dogs?
It's the big dog meta.
It was a big dog day.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
But yeah, I felt really bad because I was like, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry you have no friends right now.
I'm just like, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry you gotta be a loner.
I'm so sorry, dad.
And I didn't mean to make you more upset.
I thought it was gonna be a fun day for him.
I was like, yeah, I'm gonna do some exercise with him.
We're gonna go out.
He's gonna make some new friends.
And then I ended up making his day fucking worse.
I was like, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to make your day worse.
For having you look at the other dogs having fun.
And you can't even do anything about it.
And you just have to look.
I'm like, I'm so sorry.
I thought people would bring in small dogs today.
Oh my god.
One is the loneliest number.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi Toki.
Former dog dad after 14 years with a basset hound.
Ear cleaning is important.
Yeah, I'm gonna start cleaning his ears more after the medication.
Like I used to not do it.
It wasn't me doing the ear cleaning.
So I wasn't sure how many times I was supposed to clean his ears.
Because I know when I took him to the groomers, they cleaned his ears.
But I wasn't sure how many times I was supposed to clean it in general.
Because my dad used to do it all the time.
But now I know.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
But it has been helping him, his scratches.
Because I feel like he doesn't scratch anymore, other than his ears.
But now I know why he's scratching his ears.
Because he literally has a fucking yeast infection.
So I was like, oh, that's why.
I was like, that makes so much more sense now.
Because he stopped scratching overall, except for his ears.
And then the vet was like, yeah, he has a yeast infection in his ear.
And I'm like, oh, okay.
And I'm like, okay.
And then I was like, is he okay?
Like, did I...
Did I...
Like...
Are his ears damaged?
And then she was...
The vet was like, no, no, it's just clogged up.
So, like, you just need to clean it.
Like, he can...
It's fine.
Like, the moment you clean it, it's fine.
There's no damage.
Permanent damage or anything.
It's just, like, a really clogged up ear.
Like...
I was like, oh, thank God.
He's like...
She's like, yeah, it didn't affect, like, his inner eardrum.
So don't worry.
It's just the outer area.
So, like, he'll be okay.
It's just very clogged up with yeast.
And, like...
And bacteria.
And I'm like, oh...
Okay, that's good to know.
That's good to know.
I was like, that's why it's extra scratchy.
And I'm like, oh, that makes more sense.
Like, he literally stopped scratching other than his ears.
So I'm like, okay.
That's good to know.
That's...
That's very good to know.
Thank you for the Aka so far.
Thank you.
Yeah, he's...
He's...
He's a problem.
He's just...
He's just a little genetic mess right now.
Alright, before, like, I give...
I actually have a lot of stories to tell today.
But we're playing Crime Scene Cleaner.
So I was...
I wanted to do a little, like, chatting stream.
But I didn't want to be just chatting.
So, like, I decided to play, like, a cleaning game.
Because cleaning games tend to be, like...
Tend to be, like, you know...
You can chat while you clean.
And I was, like, debating either doing Power Wash Simulator or...
Sorry, I have hiccups right now.
Or...
And then I found this one.
Crime Scene Cleaner.
I was like, oh, that's cool.
Basically, it's, like...
It's literally, like, Power Wash Simulator.
But you're cleaning blood instead of dirt.
So I was like, oh, that's...
That's...
That's neat.
That's educational.
Like, what if you're, like, you know...
I mean, I feel like that's incredibly educational.
Because what if you're, like, you know...
Full or safe?
Okay, we're turning off HeadBob.
I think HeadBob is not great in general.
I was like, you know, like...
What if, like, you know...
You accidentally stumbled onto...
Somebody fell and, like, you know...
Tripped and died.
And then, like, you know...
People...
You don't want people to blame you for the accident and murder.
So I was like, that's educational, you know?
Like, what if you are put in a situation...
Where you have to clean...
Clean up.
And, like, you don't want people to think it's you.
So it's good to know.
It's good to know in the future, you know?
Try to make sure that you'll be okay.
If it's an accident, it's not a murder.
Exactly!
But, like...
You gotta make...
You gotta hide...
If you hide the evidence, then there was never an accident.
If you think about it.
So then you don't have to deal with, like...
You don't have to deal with police.
You don't have to deal with...
Like...
With, like...
A court order.
You don't have to deal with, like...
You know...
Like...
Family of the victim.
And everything.
So...
Having no evidence is better than having evidence.
But this is all hypothetical, of course.
This is all very hypothetical.
Um...
Jay!
Thank you for your very first Super Chat!
Thank you!
Doki, you're my number one motivation!
Can you get a happy birthday in Cantonese?
Of course!
Sayonara!
Jay!
Thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you!
All right.
I know...
It'll be very interesting.
And, like...
You get to learn how to clean a crime.
I heard, like, this game is very relaxing.
Yeah, crime scene cleaning is a natural...
I used to watch, like, YouTube shorts...
Of a professional...
professional crime scene cleaner.
Oh.
Wait, there's a story?
I used to watch, like, YouTube shorts of, like, a crime scene cleaner.
And he would tell, like, stories about, like, his life as a crime scene cleaner.
And he also cleans for, like, people who have, like, hoarding issues.
Like, who are hoarders.
And he does, like, those, like, free cleanings for other people.
There are people just for people who have issues with...
...have hoarding issues and stuff.
Yeah, it's very...
It's a very interesting chat.
There's also that lady that cleans abandoned graves.
Yeah, I know.
I was like, why does this have a story?
Wait!
I am!
I am a... I am hiding...
I told you this was going to be educational!
Wait!
I am trying to hide it!
I told you guys!
I told you this is educational!
I'm hiding evidence!
Because of an accident!
How do I get in?
Open the codex.
You can check all the active questionnaire if you got lost.
Okay.
Look at it already?
Wait, I have a skill tree?
Oh my god!
I have a fucking skill tree!
I'm cleaning!
I'm going to level up my cleaning, guys.
Collect Tyler's payment and dispose of the body.
I assume...
Did I not look at it already?
Oh, interactions.
Okay.
Interact.
Oh, shit!
I thought I was just going to be cleaning.
I thought I was going to be relaxing like Pyrewash.
I'm actually cleaning.
What else?
Collectibles.
Oh, shit!
I can't get up!
I wonder where you will find some intriguing collectibles.
Some of them may turn out to be crime evidence.
You must take them away with you or else you will fail the mission.
Has its own icon indicating which category it belongs to.
Evidence, key, cassette, or story collectible.
Okay.
Where the fuck is the evidence?
Got to make sure.
Okay.
Punch.
Oh, I found a hidden apartment!
Is there anything in here?
For me to collect?
Let's see.
Oh, hey!
Nice!
$100.
All I'm saying is that whoever lives here is dead now.
So everything here is free for all.
Wait, what's this?
If they're dead already, I can take their money.
Okay.
I got their keys.
Oh, steal.
Nice.
It's not stealing if they're dead.
I'm just gathering evidence, guys.
It's not breaking and entering!
There's nobody that lives here!
How am I breaking and entering if nobody...
Look, eviction notice.
You're hereby required to vacate the premises within 10 days.
Keeping pets are clearly not allowed.
Exactly.
See?
Nobody lives here.
So, like, I can easily take their stuff.
Look, if I can't take their stuff, then people would say grave robbing is a crime.
Then people would say grave robbing is a crime.
A simple-minded welcome to Tamaya Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Oh, it says, secrets neck nearby.
Alright.
Not if the grave is abandoned!
Okay, if the grave is like 300-500 years old.
Okay, if grave robbing is a crime, explain museums.
is a crime, explain museums.
You can't be like, oh, but those are the British.
Explain the National Museum in New York City.
Where some of the things aren't even put to display.
They're locked up in the basement.
It was a gift from the British.
Yeah, the Smithsonian.
Explain the Smithsonian.
And you know the worst part?
They made three very successful movies about it.
To justify the grave robbing.
It's doing our best to be the intro victim It's doing our best to be the intro victim in a supernatural episode.
Snooks, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
To the mindless moron living here.
I'm so sick of you.
Sick of hearing this hippie music every single night.
Sick of all your shady looking friends banging on your door and discussing things loudly in the hallway.
You're making my life a fucking hell.
So I'm going to raise the volume a little bit.
Let me know if it's better.
Okay.
Yeah, it was a pretty tough neighborhood from what I see.
Everybody's evicted.
What neighbors?
I don't understand.
Everybody is literally evicted.
Wait, how is this so clean?
Except for that over there.
But how is...
Like, what the fuck?
This place is actually pretty decent.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh hey, another key.
Alright, alright.
Is that my blood?
Okay, we got to clean.
Collect, dispose the bodies, wipe off all the blood.
Okay, so is my feet...
Does my feet track blood?
Oh, it does.
Okay.
We got to clean this.
Alright.
Clean, clean, clean.
Don't worry.
Just spilled some red paint.
That's all.
Oh no.
Okay.
How do I...
Okay, bucket.
Alright.
Oh, we got to put down at a water source.
Hello.
I mean, there's no body.
Who's to say there was a murder if there's no body?
Okay, let me put that here.
Okay.
How do I fill this water up?
Oh, collect.
Oh wait, no.
How do I fill it up?
This is a water source.
Do I use a shower?
Oh, there it is!
Oh, there's a...
Why is there a faucet outside of the shower?
That doesn't make sense.
Alright.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh!
I use my special eyes to see all the body fluids.
I mean the paint fluids.
Alright, clean.
That's very convenient.
Yeah, I was going to say, who the fuck has that faucet thing?
Um...
I've never seen a shower, like a bathroom area with a faucet outside of the shower.
And it's not like, um...
It's not like the sink or anything.
Alright, my assassin's greed eyes.
What is it called when you put down the bucket to replace the contaminated?
What is it called when you, you know like those like magic, the flashlights?
You know those magic flashlights that, uh...
Wait, how do I put this away?
Clean.
Okay.
I need to collect... UV light!
Yeah, I have UV eyes!
I have UV eyes, guys!
That's my special talent.
It's a very terrible talent, not gonna lie.
Okay, pick up.
Then we...
We...
Make sure it's... We make sure it's new water.
It's like almost fixed.
Oh wait, I forgot this.
Oh shit!
What the fuck was that?
Is that blood?
No, it can't be blood.
Legally, it's not blood.
Guys.
Oh, I can just use my mop to just... Wait, that's convenient, actually.
That's very convenient.
You know what we mean?
Guys?
Okay.
Guys, wait.
Let me turn the music down.
And then let me...
Okay, guys.
I'm willing to risk it.
Guys, we're not gonna have...
Wait.
Come on!
Alright.
This...
This stream is gonna be demonetized.
There we go.
Cruella, Cruella De Vil.
Cruella De Vil.
Yeah!
What?
We're here to do...
It's a nice cleaning soundtrack.
Cruella De Vil.
I'm saying if I'm gonna be clean, I'm cleaning with my music.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna be cleaning...
Woah!
It's alright.
Disney Jazz!
Let's fucking go!
I don't remember this scene in the movie.
All I'm saying is that, you know when you're cleaning?
You're cleaning and you gotta... you play your own music?
It's fine, there's no body.
See, there's no body!
Free eye!
Free phone!
Yeah, it's all raspberry jam!
Exactly!
It makes the job go so much faster!
Wait, how the fuck is there blood here?
I don't understand!
Okay, we gotta get rid of this.
I know how many people were killed here!
In general!
Okay, we gotta refill this.
How do I...
How do I fucking refill this?
How do I put this away?
Oh, okay.
It's clean now.
Alright.
Let's boost game volume a little.
Don't worry, I got you.
I mean, we could listen to heavy metal.
I guess we could.
Heavy metal...
Yeah, man.
Alright, nice.
We gotta relax while we're cleaning.
I mean, I could be listening to lo-fi.
Let's get rockin'!
Yeah!
What the fuck?
Wait, Disney heavy metal!
You're right!
Alright.
Finding the right music.
Disney heavy...
Guys, finding the right song to do while you're cleaning is so difficult.
It's so...
It's so difficult.
There we go.
Alright, you're right!
Oh, hey!
Free phone!
Woah!
Wait, okay.
I need...
I need to go to the heavy metal part.
Give me a sec.
Yeah?
Oh, I erased the volume of the right wrong one.
Okay, where's, like, instrumental?
I need, like, instru- Wait, there's a Mickey Mouse watch in metal?
Wait, how does that sound like?
Okay, there you go.
Alright.
We got the evidence.
Oh my god!
The Mickey Mouse March, but heavy metal!
What the fuck?
Oh shit, I'm sorry.
I got distracted with heavy metal.
Alright.
M-I-C-K-E-Y M-O-U-S-E
M -I-C-K-E-Y M-O-U-S-E Oh shit!
Mickey Mouse!
Oh, my mom!
I'm so...
It's not productive anymore!
Oh shit, okay.
U-S-E I'm getting distracted!
Guys, I don't think...
I don't think...
Maybe...
Maybe heavy metal Disney was not...
Heavy metal was not it.
Mickey Mouse!
Hi!
I guess you're a blood puppet.
M-I-C-K-E-Y M-O-U-S-E Mickey Mouse Club!
No!
Shit!
I'm making a better mess!
Not a good cleansing cleaner!
No!
It's okay!
I can fix it!
I can't help it!
It's so good!
Okay.
Alright, let's clean this part, guys.
Alright, alright.
Back to the lo-fi.
I think I was more...
I was more focused on...
When I was clean...
When I was actually...
When I was actually listening to jazz and lo-fi.
Alright, back to lo-fi.
Alright, we're gonna go to the lo-fi.
I'm gonna listen to lo-fi now.
Alright, this...
Ba-ba-ba.
Ba-da-dum.
Ba-ba-dum.
Ba-dum-ba-ba-dum.
Ba-ba-ba-dum.
Ba -ba -ba -ba -dum.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-dum.
Ba -ba-ba-ba-dum.
Classical lo-fi.
What?
We're cleaning!
It's a relaxing time!
Guys, we can't...
Guys, we can't listen to rock!
If we listen to rock, we're not doing our job!
We're too busy jamming!
Ba-ba-dum.
We're cleaning the table.
I feel like I could use other stuff, but like...
I feel like the mop was the best.
There we go.
I say you listen to some salsa.
I feel like you're making multiple companies fight for copyright!
Wait, how did you know?
That's my key!
That's my solution!
If I'm listening to copyright songs, I make multiple companies, like, do copyright strikes.
So, like...
Not copyright strikes, but like, fight for, like, the monetization.
So it doesn't matter in the end.
Wait, how did you guys...
That's my strategy!
I actually do that!
Like, that's why I would listen to a variety of, like, not just Disney, but like, Ghibli and 2, and like, Nintendo and Pokemon.
So they all fight for, like, my monetization.
And they all want their one cent!
Oh my god!
Using mop here?
What do you mean?
It's been so effective!
I've been cleaning everything with my mop!
Okay, wait.
How do I...
Okay.
I keep forgetting.
Oh, how do I put this away?
How do I put...
No, I don't...
Put your hands away, sir!
Put your hands away!
How do I do that?
I'm trying to make him put his hands away.
How do I...
Put your hands away!
Put...
Oh, one.
Okay, there we go.
It's one.
Okay.
Cool.
Alright.
Remove hands now!
Alright, let's...
Okay, I can make the song a little quieter.
Do copyright things get cut out of the super chats?
No, they don't!
It's just monetization.
That's why I don't care sometimes.
Because like, as long as I can have the super chats, that's fine.
I just feel like it's more relaxing to clean with lo-fi.
Oh, it's the run!
Can you just move the bucket?
Yeah, I'm about to clean the bucket too, and that's like... that's too much.
I'd rather just go back.
I don't want to refill the bucket.
I'd rather just run back and forth.
Can we clean one?
Yeah, but I'm not focused when I'm cleaning with electric swing.
Okay, how about I give you guys... I can give you guys Nintendo Jazz.
Alright.
Guys, I know we're never going to listen to a full song, but like...
Yeah, it's about the cardio, chat.
It's the cardio.
Alright, let me give you guys Nintendo... Okay, gaming jazz music.
Okay, you're not focused.
There you go.
Let's listen to some jazz.
Alright, this should work.
I guess like if I'm... if I have to use a sponge here, right?
Alright, scrub, scrub, scrub.
Scrub, scrub.
Alright, this is... we're not swapping for now.
We're going to swap until after this playlist is done.
Yeah, not just any kind of jazz, but gaming jazz.
I might be late tonight, sorry.
You want a date or something, Cathy?
No, just going to buy.
Just going to buy some... some devil's lettuce and have fun.
Alright, see you... wait, he killed?
He killed somebody for the devil's lettuce?
You can get that like... you can go to a dispensary.
What?
You can literally... you can literally go to a dispensary.
It's not even illegal anymore.
In like some states in America.
Isn't it?
Yeah.
Yeah, I was going to say.
Stab to death?
Oh shit!
Alright, let me clean this up first.
Look, if I want to get to the body, I don't want to get my... my feet like dirty here.
Alright, let's just clean this up real fast.
Alright, let's clean this... clean this body real fast.
Okay.
Pick up and throw.
Once you find a dead body, it should be removed from the crime scene.
Pick it up and take it.
Oh, okay.
There's my cleaner sense.
I have a bucket too?
Fearing the ability... the better bucket can create a combinations of stuff.
Oh, you're right.
Animal Crossing tunes.
You're right.
It's so hard to find nice music to...
Oh, you're right.
We should listen to some Animal Crossing coffee shop.
Alright.
There we go.
This is the last time we swap music.
Alright.
Oh hey, there's some free pizza.
That's nice.
90% changing songs.
10% use just Eevee.
You played the game too hard.
Okay, let's clean the blood around.
Let's clean the blood around his body first though.
I'll make sure to clean the blood stains off your jacket too.
Because even if you're dead, you gotta look good.
You know?
Gotta make sure you're nice and clean.
Um...
Nice.
Yeah, you just spilled...
Oh, there's some blood.
That's so bloody for like one stab wound.
Like...
Like it's so bloody.
Literally, it's just one stab.
How did you lose that much blood?
It's not even like...
Like his jacket's not even that bloody.
Don't understand.
It's a mega stab.
It's not just...
No, it is.
See, it's one guy.
See?
It's literally one guy.
Oh my god, wait.
Is it two guys?
Wait a minute.
Is this two guys?
Oh shit, Cathy!
Seems like our guy had another hobby.
Oh, wait.
Oh, okay.
It's just one girl.
Okay, that's fine.
I mean, that's not fine.
But like...
It's less fucked up.
It's...
I thought, you know...
I thought like it was very...
Relevant to like a current situation.
Like a current court case that's going on right now.
And I was like, oh fuck.
Is this like a pair...
Like...
Like a reference to that?
And I was like, oh, okay.
It's...
It's just one girl for now.
There's no baby oil anywhere.
There's no...
Okay.
All right.
Well...
Well, we have two murders.
We gotta...
We gotta clean up now.
Okay.
We're gonna...
Don't worry.
It's pretty relaxing though.
A little more music.
There's not much going on in game.
All right.
We'll boost up the music too.
Oh, yeah.
I should be using...
I don't know why I'm using my sponge.
I could use...
I could use my mop now.
Papa Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was off the grid for a week and itching like a dookie in a card shop.
Thank you for the super chat, Smurf.
Thank you.
Okay.
Let's see.
You think I can refill this?
Yeah, I think so.
Oh, let's clean our sponge too.
Our sponge needs some cleaning as well.
All right.
Oh, is this more evidence?
Oh, nice.
At least he's...
Oh, he doesn't try his product.
Good for him.
But what's this?
That's a bong.
What does he have a bong then?
Like...
Messy!
I don't know how to read this.
Oh, it's just...
He's the same.
I don't know.
I can't find it.
I think I lost it.
Okay.
Let's do this.
I've done this a number of times.
Oh, please.
Oh, my gosh.
It's just a informaes cache.
I just saved you guys a pep time.
Which gives you a chance to plan for your schedule.
Tweet.
Okay.
Alright.
Is there any blood here?
Okay, there's blood here.
That's fine.
Oh, I should pick up the- I'll pick up the trash later.
Alright, boost up the music a little bit and also the game volume.
What's this?
Oh shit!
Oh, it's classical music!
We should listen to classical music!
Oh my god!
We should listen to some nice classical music!
Alright.
Classical music that slaps.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh!
Is that one lady?
Okay, it's two ladies.
Alright.
It's time to do my job.
I should use a sponge.
Oh shit!
Sorry.
Sorry, ma'am.
Okay, how do I get down from here?
What?
It's copyright free after playing several copyright music!
This is copyright free!
We should be safe now.
We should be safe now!
I'm sorry, I think that Doki might be a psycho.
What do you mean?
I'm trying to- I'm just trying to find the perfect music to clean!
Ahem.
Look, it still works, man!
I don't care if you think it's ineffective!
I'm still cleaning!
Since we're challenging copyright tonight, here's a request for Disney Eurobee.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm just making sure this lady is nice and clean.
Nice.
Don't worry, I'll clean your clothes up a little bit too.
There we go.
Is the music loud enough?
Wait, there's a faucet there?
Oh, bring that bucket over.
Alright, let's bring that bucket over.
There's a closer...
Oh, my water!
Oh.
Okay, that's fine.
It's too...
Alright, there's a... there's a... Oh, no!
No, my bucket!
Alright.
It's alright.
Oh, there it is!
Nice.
Okay, that's very convenient, actually.
Alright.
Alright, is that everything?
Okay.
Oh, so...
Oh, my God!
Wait, he uses the blood to paint pictures?
Holy shit!
You guys call me crazy?
Bro, this guy uses the blood of his victims!
To, like... to, like, paint!
This guy's fucking insane!
All I'm doing is listening to classical music while cleaning!
How creative!
Well, people... some people say this... my... my stuff is creative, too.
I guess, like...
I guess we're gonna throw this away.
Can I not throw his art away?
I guess not?
Oh, I guess... I can't throw his art away.
I guess it's too beautiful.
Unless I use detergent.
Oh, I can...
Oh, I should've been using detergent!
I should've been using normal.
No, he drew a chicken.
And, like...
A rocket ship.
I mean, he's very creative.
Like...
Competing with a psycho.
I'm not competing with a psycho!
I'm saying...
I don't understand why you compare me to him when he literally is, like...
Oh, I can break it!
Oh, I have to break his art!
No, but I could still do it!
I could sell for money!
I could just be like, that's chicken blood!
You know?
I could just be like, that's chicken blood.
It's not real... It's not real human blood.
They can't tell.
Blood is blood.
I'm pretty sure, like, human blood is, like, the same smell as, like, chicken blood.
Well, crazy, yes.
The only difference is there are psychopaths like this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Can I grab this?
Okay.
Alright.
Collect multiple.
There we go.
Alright.
How does she know that?
I assume blood... No, it's just... It's just an assumption, guys!
It is just an assumption, everybody!
Like, it's just using critical thinking!
Alright.
Are we removing evidence?
I told you this is educational.
Like, this is something you should be doing.
Okay.
How do I... Why is this not going into the trash?
It belongs in the trash.
Oh, I have to punch it!
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
For a serial killer?
I mean, like...
Maybe... Maybe those ladies deserve it.
Maybe they're also serial killers and this is a Dexter scenario.
We don't know that.
This could be, like, Dexter.
We don't know what the ladies have been doing and that one guy.
That lady could have been, like...
What was it?
The Zodiac Killer.
We don't know that.
I don't think they...
They could easily be the Zodiac Killer.
We don't have evidence that they're innocent.
Alright.
Is the music okay now?
Let's see the evidence here.
Well, now we're here.
Oh, it's too... How many ladies has it been?
Oh, yeah.
This guy was a little freaky.
Like, look at them toes.
Okay.
What's this?
Ropes and Knots.
This book sells through the history types and use of ropes while trying together detailed instructions, illustrations, and practical applications of various knots.
Oh!
Is this a real book?
By Albert de Salle...
Wait, is this real?
Wait, is this a real book?
Ropes and Knots book.
Albert...
I'm just... It's for science.
Albert de Salvo, Jr. Was a...
Don't look him up.
I don't get it.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, let's put this body away.
Don't worry.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
If you really want to know, you can look him up yourself.
You can look him...
You can look him up yourself.
Alright, time to put this body away.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Nobody's gonna know.
They'll just think it's like...
A wax figure.
Or like those mannequins.
Wait, am I just...
Do I just...
Put him in my car?
Like...
Just like that?
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
He'll be in the body bag right next to you.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say like...
With everybody can see it in the open.
What am I gonna say?
Like, everybody's gonna see me chuck a fucking body in the car.
I feel like it's not...
Oh, did I break something?
Shattered...
Or...
If you want to avoid access shadowing, you should use a sponge.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
Everything's already broken.
Yeah, nobody's gonna suspect a thing.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Just gotta make sure that's okay.
We'll do the trash last.
I need to get rid of the body first.
Okay.
Alright, put that away.
And then we're gonna put you...
Put you in my trunk.
Don't worry, nobody will remember you.
And I'm gonna find where Cathy lives.
So I'll tie up all loose ends.
Do not worry.
Or I'm just gonna make her forget about you.
Don't worry.
Cathy is gonna be so lonely.
But she won't be lonely when I find her.
I'm quite a charmer, you know?
Alright, let's see.
Into the truck you go.
Alright.
Yeah, I know.
One more body up there.
I still need to throw the...
I need to throw the trash away, though.
Okay.
That's creepy.
What is?
I was just gonna comfort her.
She's gonna be a widow.
So, like, we gotta show some compassion.
Where is the other body?
Where did I put the other...
Oh, there she is.
Alright.
Get up here.
Like, who is...
Do I get paid a lot of money for this?
I must have.
I mean, if, like, I'm here to clean up the evidence...
I must get a lot of money for doing this.
That's pretty low, Jokey.
What?
She's gonna be so sad.
I'm just gonna be cheering her up.
I'm gonna make sure she's gonna have a good time.
And forget about her deadbeat ex.
That totally left her.
I'm gonna be there.
I was like, yeah.
Jeremy told me...
Oh, God.
Okay, we gotta get over there.
Get over...
Try it.
Oh!
I'm sorry!
I'll be like, yeah, your deadbeat ex left you.
What a fucking asshole.
Oh, my God.
Sorry.
I'm playing...
I'm playing basketball right now.
I'll just be like, I'm so sorry.
I can't believe he would leave you like this.
He was...
I saw him with another woman.
And then he was like, yeah, Kathy will never know.
And that's why I'm here to tell you, Kathy, that you deserve so much better.
Anyway, don't go looking for him.
He already left to the town next over.
And he said, like, he already left.
Oh, hey, money.
At least he didn't screw me over.
Oh, my God.
That's a lot of $100 bill.
From, like, the devil's lettuce?
That's so much money.
I thought it's like...
I thought they had dispensaries in America.
Bum, bum, ba-dum.
But Kathy will believe me.
I know I'm a stranger, but she's gonna believe me.
Okay, we're gonna throw away this trash.
Where is the trash?
Oh, I guess, like, I have to put it in my...
She will.
I'm just gonna have to...
I'm gonna do, like, that thing in that old movie where, like, people, they use, like, a dead body to pretend he's alive and take, like, lots of pictures.
I'll just use that.
I'll just put...
I'll use that dead body.
Clean it up.
Put him in nicer clothes.
Put him next to the other...
The women dead body.
Two women dead bodies.
And then, like, put them together and take pictures with them together.
And be like, look at these pictures.
I found him at the bar with these two ladies.
Yeah!
The Bernie!
We can have Bernies!
And then I'll dress them up, like, in nicer clothes.
Clean them up so there's no blood or anything.
And then just be like, I can't believe he would do this to you.
You deserve so much better.
Okay, that's fine.
Is there anything more blood here?
Oh, that's where I spilled the water.
Okay, we're gonna clean this area, too.
And that handprint.
I think that's it, right?
Okay, and this, too.
Okay, and then we just gotta...
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I gotta put stuff away.
So that's here.
Um, we're hang...
We're gonna hang that back so that everything is where it's supposed to be.
And then...
Where is this?
Okay, that's here.
Okay, and then...
That's here.
Oh, shit.
We gotta put the pillow away, too.
Put this here.
How did I know that's where things are?
Cleaning comes before fixing?
But there's nothing to clean here.
What do you mean?
There's literally nothing here.
Okay, wipe all the blood.
But there's nothing here.
It's just a little blood.
What is there to be worried about?
Just a little blood.
They're not gonna...
They're not gonna look that much into it.
What are they, cops?
Like, if there's blood in my apartment right now, I wouldn't notice it if it's, like, a little bit of blood.
Like, who pays attention to that?
Like...
What do you mean?
Okay, check your...
Alright, get a UV light right now and check if, like...
See if you actually notice if there's a little blood.
I bet you won't.
I bet you won't notice the tiny blood you have.
Oh, hey.
Yeah.
I mean, like, how are they gonna know?
Crime scene investigation...
Who's gonna report this crime?
Like...
Who's gonna know that he went to buy the devil?
Devil's lettuce.
Oh, Kathy.
Okay, but, like, if we get Kathy out of the picture, who's gonna know?
If we get Kathy out of the picture, nobody will know.
We already committed three murders.
What's one more to go?
They never caught the Zodiac Killer.
You think they're gonna catch me?
They never catch the Zodiac Killer.
They won't catch me.
Bro, just leave Kathy alone.
What are you gonna do to Kathy?
They...
No, they didn't.
Who's the Zodiac Killer?
Who is he?
You guys don't know.
Wait, don't...
They'll never get...
They'll never know.
That's because the Zodiac Killer was smart.
The Zodiac Killer did not stream their crime.
The Zodiac Killer is smart.
Why did they get him?
Why did nobody tell me they got the Zodiac Killer?
I feel like that's so important.
Pennywise, two boxes of K.
What is this?
Nothing.
This motherfucker still owes me 5k.
Oh, he...
No, he sells more than just the Devil's Lettuce.
I assume, like, 3Gs a C is like...
Did you guys see that on Twitter?
Where people were, like, like, I don't know.
Like, was it smoking?
Does... wait, what was it?
They were trying to justify doing, like, Cs.
But, like, doing the powder?
Yeah, somebody, people on Twitter were trying to justify doing the powder.
And saying, like, the powder, like, Coke Zero does more damage.
It's like, people were like, guys, Coke Zero does more damage than actual powder.
And people were like, no?
They're like, let some girls have fun.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
Where did you learn that fact?
Yeah, it got community noted.
Like...
It got... it got community noted.
Because people were like, that's not true.
Like, Angel, thank you for the one gift and chip.
Thank you, thank you.
I was like, where did you get that information?
Alright.
Okay, that should be clean now.
Onto the table you go.
And then you are here.
And then... you're here.
And then the chair is here.
They're... they're... they're...
Okay, where does this table go?
Wait, where does this table go?
Oh, it's over here.
I mean, he lives in a nice area.
Like, his own apartment is nice.
It's just the outside is pretty fucked.
I guess he wants to be, like, non...
Like, what... the most surprising part about this entire building is that the bathroom has... is actually pretty decent.
Okay, never mind.
Never mind.
It's... he has a washing machine in his bathroom.
That's kind of a little freaky.
Uh, I take it back.
That's a little freaky.
That's... that's a little freaky.
Oh, hey, five dollars.
Oh, a hundred dollars.
That's nice.
Overcoming... Oh, he has anger issues.
How to deal with your violent urges.
Overcoming aggression.
Oh my god, speaking of, like, violent urge... I don't have violent urges.
But speaking of violent urges, I was, like, reading up on T.J.
Miller.
Oh, you guys know who T.J.
Miller is?
He's a guy who was in Silicon Valley and, like, um, he used to be in Deadpool or something.
And apparently he's, like, super hard to work with.
Um, because... because I was, like, wait, what happened to that guy?
He was everywhere and then he was nowhere.
Because I was curious.
I was, like, he used to be, like, so famous and you would see him everywhere.
And then suddenly he, like, disappeared and everything.
And then I was, like, I was reading up on him.
Because, like, apparently, um, he, like, he had an argument with a lady on a train.
And then he had, like, he had, like, a breakdown.
He had, like, a psychosis breakdown.
And called a bomb threat on the train.
So, obviously, all the movie companies fucking dropped him.
Because they're, like, holy shit, that's fucked.
But, like, it's apparently it's also because he has, like, um, he has, like, brain damage.
That was discovered in 2010.
So he would, he has, like, bipolar.
But, like, only the manic episodes are bipolar.
So he doesn't have, like...
The other stuff from it.
But, like, he has, like, the, like, the, the manic episodes and stuff.
So I was, like, holy shit.
And so he, like, lost, like, a lot of his, like, the job.
Like, he's a really good actor.
But, like, yeah, he had, like, um, he had, like, um, an issue with one of the lobes in his brain.
That caused him to have, like, manic episodes and stuff.
Yeah.
He's not very funny.
He, he's really good at...
Quote, unquote, acting like an asshole.
But, like, in the end, he actually...
He does...
He is, like, an asshole.
But it's not, like, his fault.
Um...
So it was, like, so fucked.
Because I was, like, he used to be in, like, everywhere, too.
He used to be, like, in, like, so many things.
Like, he was in Big Hero 6.
He was big...
He was in Big Hero 6.
And he was in, like, uh...
He was, like, in How to Train Your Dragon, Silicon Valley, Deadpool.
And then suddenly he was in nothing.
And I was, like, whoa.
Like, what the fuck happened to him?
I was, like, that's so interesting.
And his mom...
Okay, the most interesting part is that his mom is a psychologist, too.
So I was, like, holy...
I was, like...
I was, like, oh, my God.
He has, like, so many resources, too, to, like, help him.
It's really...
He recently made a Reddit post on, like...
Like, a Reddit post AMA.
And he was, like, yeah, like, I'm working really hard.
With my psycholo...
Like, psychologists and, like, therapy and everything.
So he is getting the help, which is nice to see.
I was, like...
It was so, like, interesting, though.
Because, like, it's really interesting what, like, marketing and, like, what the public perception is can affect the story.
Because I was reading how people were, like, thinking he was just, like, an incredibly huge asshole.
And was, like...
Was, like, oh, yeah, no, people hate working with him and stuff.
Like, Ryan Reynolds fucking hate him.
And that's why he got dropped for Deadpool...
Uh, Deadpool 3.
And I was, like...
Because he was in Deadpool 1 and 2.
But he wasn't in...
But they literally forgot about him in Deadpool 3.
And so I was, like...
So I was, like, oh, what happened to him?
And then, apparently, it was not even his fault.
It's just because...
It's just because he just has, like...
He literally can't help it.
Whoops.
Uh...
Here we go.
But, yeah, people were saying he's, like, super hard to work with.
What is your Twitter timeline?
Okay...
I played...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, that didn't come up on my Twitter.
I was just super curious.
I was, like, what happened to TJ Miller?
Like...
I was just curious.
I looked it up.
Because I was, like, what the fuck happened to that guy?
I think that's it, right?
Did I fix everything?
It's, like, nothing bad happened here.
Oh, the other subject?
Which one?
I went through so many different subjects.
Which...
Which one?
You gotta be specific here.
One...
One evidence and one furniture.
And I'm trying to figure out which one is it.
Where's the last furniture?
I feel like everything is, like, where it's supposed to be.
Oh, the Diet Coke?
What?
It's cause, like...
People were, like...
Please...
Please do not listen to this random Twitter person that says...
Coke Zero is worse than...
They're, like...
Drugs are still bad.
No matter what.
Do not...
Just because...
Just because they seem quirky...
Doesn't mean that they're right.
I was just, like...
Holy shit.
That's so fucking...
That's so fucking crazy.
I was, like...
What?
Oh, there it is.
The fucking...
I thought that this was supposed to be there.
Like...
That thought process needs to be studied.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Twitter is a very interesting place.
It's a very...
It's very interesting.
What evidence?
What kind of ev...
Oh.
What kind of evidence do I need?
I feel like I collected everything.
Like...
How can he get even more crazy?
Is it in the attic?
Okay.
Let's check the attic real fast.
All right.
Like, what other crazy shit do you have up here?
Bum, bum.
Okay.
That's a ladder.
Is there anything here?
Oh.
Nice.
Okay.
We need that, actually.
What's this?
Oh, okay.
Those are...
Oh.
There's more...
Oh, there's more...
More devil's lettuce.
All right.
Anything else?
Oh, nice.
More.
Guys, I know a guy.
Is there anything else here?
I guess there's like power tools, TV.
I feel like that's everything.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, it's her.
Tabitha Coons.
Simmons University.
Replacement fee.
Well, Tabitha's not gonna need it.
I don't need this anymore.
Yay!
I can sell this ID.
Alright, now for... I might as well get some identity theft going along too.
Alright.
I think we're good.
It's like nobody was here.
I mean like, you might as well fully commit.
You already commit so many crimes.
Why stop now?
Kill the rabbit.
Are you sure you will not be able to continue cleaning?
Yeah, alright.
Alright, we can go now.
Yay!
We did our job!
Yeah, we can't end it on a lame crime.
We gotta...
We gotta fully commit.
Look at that.
100%.
I'm really good.
I'm a natural.
Someone can say I'm a natural.
What is this?
Oh my god.
This might be my calling.
I should quit and become a crime scene leader.
Okay, nice.
I stole...
It's not stealing.
It's like...
Rent, you know?
Like...
I'm just taking extra taxes.
It's like a donation.
My super chat.
Oh, there's two other cassette tapes.
Wait, there were secrets?
What kind of secrets were there?
You like Disney sing-along songs?
Their early work was a little too new way for my taste.
But when the Little Mermaid came out, I think they really came into our own commercially and artistically.
Yeah, and then like the 2020...
2015 happened and then it just went downhill.
What is the secret?
I looked straight at the secret.
Wait, but what could it be?
Wait, what are the secrets though?
Oh, I can open my skill tree.
It's not stealing.
It's collecting.
Let's see.
Oh, it's hitting rooms?
What the fuck is that sound?
What is...
What is that sound?
What the fuck is that sound?
Oh my god, it's getting louder.
Oh my... Oh fuck, that's a dog.
Okay, I was like...
Okay, I don't know what that sound is.
What is clapping cheeks right now?
What is it?
Oh wait, I don't want to increase... Okay, mop.
Strength increases mop ability.
Clean difficulty.
Oh wait, I want the 20... Okay, we're gonna grab that.
And then cleaning speed, we'll have that.
What are tools do I have?
Increased capacity.
An additional lamp.
I feel like we don't really need that.
Okay, we need more water.
A job like that probably wouldn't work for you.
People nearby would be like, what is that laugh?
Nowhere!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Yes, save.
Oh my god, the clapping.
Please stop.
Stop the clapping, please.
Go grab this.
Oh, can I do...
Sponges get stained.
Okay, I feel like...
I feel like the stain is better.
Oh my god, please.
I'm going fucking crazy.
I'm going...
I'm going fucking...
I'm going crazy with this.
Please.
Okay.
Pressure, water, increased strength.
Pressure, strength.
Okay, maybe a difficult...
Obviously the coverage would be better though.
Okay.
Oh my god, please stop.
Please.
What's...
What!
Is it me?
It's like...
It's like that famous story where you can hear the heartbeat from the fucking floor, from the underneath the...
like floor, because it's like you're Sin or whatever.
And it's just...
Dear Mr. Kovalosky, I hope this message finds you well.
I'm writing a friend update on your phone.
Oh, I'm doing this for my daughter!
An extended pyramid.
The crow, yeah.
The telltale heart.
Please.
Where's the phone?
That's cute.
Never more book club.
Me?!
This is my dad cave?
Oh my god, I got the job!
I passed!
Guys, I passed!
Guys!
I did it!
I passed the job!
Oh, it's done.
I knew it after.
Okay, it's not as bad now.
I knew, I knew I wasn't guilty.
I was just doing my job.
Guys, I know the music doesn't sound like great, but like I was doing my job.
Look, I can change the atmosphere like instantly.
Classical music, but happy.
There you go.
I can change the feel.
I did it.
I did a good job.
Yay!
You truly are a God's gift to all fucknuts like me.
I'm not a bad person.
Definitely not a natural born killer.
But that asshole caught me off guard.
It was either him or me.
But I found the women!
Honestly, I hope you found the envelope and you're not mad that to make a swift...
Like, I found the women!
You can't just say that!
I...
Is that NordVPN?
Wait, is it?
No, it's been only five years since your wife passed away.
But truly terrible weather combined with air pollution sped up the weathering of tombstones.
I can offer you a 20% discount for your wife's grave restoration.
It'll only be $320.
It's a bargain, believe me.
Oh my God.
Wait, that...
Wait, I can just call that lady that does, like, grave cleaning and she'll do it for free for content.
Why do I need to pay you when I can pay that...
Oh, it is NordVPN.
I can pay that YouTube lady to, like, clean my wife's grave for free.
And I'll just be like, you can fucking make content out of it.
I don't care.
You make more content out of it.
Maybe people will, like...
More people will show up to clean my wife's grave.
She even less sponsored.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, where am I?
Go to bed?
Where's my bed?
Where's my bedroom?
Oh, there it is.
No, that's the bathroom.
This is... Oh, that's sad.
This is my child's room.
She is seriously ill.
Oh, no.
At least she has a job.
Oh, and she wants to be an astronaut.
Oh, that's so sad.
She's sick.
Where do I sleep?
Is this my bed?
Open up.
What am I hiding in that bedroom?
Where the fuck do I sleep?
Oh, there it is.
What the fuck is in there, then?
Alright.
Oh, there's my dead wife.
Those are the hospital bills I have to pay.
And then...
This is my beer when I drink away my problems.
Okay, that makes sense.
Alright, now I see the story of this game.
Now I understand.
Mike's spa and wellness.
What if that motherfucker finds out?
No worries, pals.
He's too dumb to suspect that...
I'll do anything for money.
Beer o'clock.
Just don't you get out of delay, small one gentleman.
What?
Why would I question anything?
If they'll pay me lots of money.
Don't bite the hand that feeds you, you know?
Whoa.
Death to traitors.
Oh, shit.
Oh, hey, look.
Some free rubber duckies for my sick daughter.
The moment I clean these rubber duckies, she's gonna love it.
Oh, hey, scrub daddy.
Alright.
Alright, time to change up the music.
Alright, guys.
Let's see.
Look, this is important.
I can't just...
I can't just stop.
Give me a sec.
Relaxing Super Mario Jazz covers.
There we go.
Alright, where's my phone?
Oh, no, the clacking is back.
Oh, shit, you're right.
Minecraft music.
I'm impressed by what she did in his apartment.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Better.
Stop dreaming for me or I'll have someone else wiping your blood off my shoes.
I mean, it's pretty fair.
...to working for the biggest crime boss in the city.
Did you hear that?
We're gonna be rich!
Working for a crime boss?
Nothing ever bad happens to those people.
Right?
Forget about it.
Hahaha.
They even made a popular cartoon show about it.
Where they forget about it.
And then it got cancelled.
But other than the cancelled part, it seemed pretty great.
Okay, bad call.
Oh, five thousand...
Okay, five thousand dollars just to fucking clean bot.
That's...
Okay, that's a little too cheap though.
I'm not gonna...
Okay, I'm gonna say, like, five thousand dollars is way too cheap for cleaning fucking bodies.
Like, it should be, like, at least...
At least ten grand!
Like, five thousand dollars?
Like...
Oh, true.
No taxes.
That's true.
There isn't any taxes.
So, like, that's the benefit.
Alright.
Yeah, that barely...
That pays for, like, one month...
Like, almost one...
Okay, one month of rent and groceries.
Like, I might as well work at, like, fat...
Like, fast food.
And then, like, it's unmarked bills too.
So, then I have to figure out how to fuck...
How the fuck to use this cash.
Like, legally.
If it's unmarked.
Okay.
Collect...
Oh, wait.
I...
Wrong level.
I did this again.
Whoops.
Uh...
Oh, no.
Abandon mission.
I went to the wrong...
I went to the wrong place.
Okay.
We're gonna skip that.
Oh, no one wondered.
Okay.
That...
So, the first job was $5,000?
Okay.
Oh, I have to accept it in my...
Um...
In my computer.
I'll never know what's making that fucking clack noise.
It's my guilty conscience.
Hey, dad.
I know you're busy working, but I want to let you know how I'm doing.
It's so weird living without you, but I'm slowly getting used to the place.
We have normal classes.
There are other kids my age, and some of them are really nice.
There are...
Uh...
I think they even want to be friends.
I even...
Yes, it's not even as bad as I thought, but I really miss you.
Yeah, I hope I can see...
Oh, my dog is...
Dexter.
Your application for a loan was rejected.
Sadly, with your current janitor salary, you don't qualify for any of our offers.
No!
Oh, $7,500?
Okay.
$7,500 ain't so bad.
It seems like a...
Good job.
All right.
Now I can go to the car.
All right, Dexter.
Oh, there's no water in there.
Let me...
Whoops.
Okay.
I'm a little bit of a mess.
All right.
Don't worry.
You'll find some stuff around to eat.
I believe in you, Dexter.
Oh, I should pet Dexter.
Dexter, who's a good boy?
How are you doing, Dexter?
Yeah.
Daddy started a criminal prison.
Did you know I'm a criminal now, little boy?
You're going to be so well fed.
Oh, my God.
A little bit.
Don't worry.
We might not have food now, but when I'm back, Dexter, we're going to have so much food.
All right.
Here we go.
Trial by blood.
Is this...
That should be it.
Okay.
Nice.
It'll be a long night.
We'll be fine.
Trial by blood.
The man you never met.
Oh!
Wait, he killed his family?
What did they do?
I guess they betrayed him, right?
Because it's like, traitor something something.
I'm here!
Yes?
Hello.
Hello, Mr. Cuff.
I'm now taking charge of the place of inheritance from my cousin,
Miss.
But how many people did he kill?
I'm getting down to work.
That's what I like to hear.
Okay, unraveling.
The grand life-size Anubis statue.
Impress your friends.
Alright.
Alright, it's cleaning time.
Doing the thing I'm most well known for.
Clean, clean, clean.
Wait, is there like a...
Oh, okay, the men's room.
Alright, we're gonna clean this part.
And then grab a bucket so I can...
Where's my bucket?
Where's my trash can?
That's...
Oh, what's this?
Oh, this is my pressure washer.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, don't worry.
Wait, is there a faucet nearby?
Oh, there it is.
Alright, I'm learning so much.
I'm learning so much on how to be an optimal cleaner.
Okay, I wonder where there's secrets here.
Okay, where does this go?
Okay, it goes here.
It's not here?
There we go.
We'll just put this here for now.
How convenient, yeah?
Okay, detergent.
Which one do I want to use?
Get stain, increase tool abilities to clean...
Okay, I feel like this is the better detergent.
Alright, and then...
Magic happens.
There we go.
Nice.
I wonder if this is like... is this like bleached water or like regular?
I guess it's regular water because there's detergent on here too.
Okay, I gotta make sure I have no evidence of my footsteps and everything.
And I'm wearing gloves!
I'm such a professional.
Okay, we gotta clean the jar a little bit and then...
There we go.
Yeah, it's Minecraft music.
I feel like that's like the best way to clean.
And then we'll sponge it up.
There we go.
It's like nothing bad ever happened.
And then we're gonna put this here so people know we're a clean building.
I mean, if you're gonna do a good job...
We might as well...
Okay, it's on the other side.
If we're gonna do a good job, we have to...
We have to have the perfect music.
Oh, relaxation zone!
Alright,
let's get this out of the way.
Make sure everything is okay.
I mean, if we're gonna take over this business...
Like, we gotta make sure that the customer...
Knows that there's no red paint every...
It's supposed to be a relaxing spa.
A dirty spa is not relaxing.
Not creepy.
It's just cause there's no people here.
Doesn't mean it's creepy.
Look, see?
Even the pool is Kool-Aid.
That's pretty neat.
Even have like Kool-Aid colored pools.
Look at that.
Good for them.
Oop.
I gotta make sure this is clean.
Yeah, it's to die for.
What flavor?
Raspberry flavor, of course.
It's Kool-Aid.
Wait, whose phone is that?
Slaps top of basketball.
Is that fucking mean?
I feel like it makes the swimming pool more fun if it's different colors.
It's nice Halloween themed.
Alright.
With this pastor eating Mama Mia's make me sick.
Alright, nice.
I mean, they deserve it.
Like, literally.
Like, why would you ever try to kill your boss?
If you're gonna kill your boss, at least like get away with it.
Dude.
Hire...
Never be the one to initiate to like suggest the killing to somebody else to do it.
So this is what I would do hypothetically if I don't...
If I wanna like, you know, attempting murder.
Like, I would not...
Obviously, I would not be the one to like try to be like, I wanna murder this person.
You'd like...
You like him to somebody else who also feels the same way.
Like, you know, they feel similar.
And then be like, yeah, he fucking sucks.
Wouldn't it be funny if like, you know, if he was dead?
But like, that's just so funny.
Wouldn't it be?
And then like, you know, get that thought and like implant that thought in his head.
Like inception.
But like IRL.
So then you inception him.
And then he'll...
He'll be the one that tries to come up and be like, yeah, no, he fucking sucks too.
Like, yeah, oh my god, he fucking sucks as well.
And then so like, they'll think about it.
And then, you know, they try to initiate a plan.
And you're just like...
And then, you know, when you find out that they try to do a murder, you'd be like, oh my god, how could Jimmy do that?
I thought he was cool.
I would never let that happen to you, boss.
In Minecraft, of course.
In Minecraft.
I'm just saying, like...
Like, the easiest way to get away...
Is to just incept someone else to think...
To do it.
And then, like, you know, you don't have to be involved.
It's all unhypothetical.
That's why we have Minecraft music playing.
Yeah.
It's all in Minecraft.
Okay, we gotta grab our fucking...
Is there another...
Oh, they got the Anubis!
They got the Anubis statue!
Hey, attention!
Alright, let's clean this up.
Oh yeah, we gotta get the...
Uh, detergent in.
Alright.
Let's put that...
Let's make sure our mop has the detergent, too.
How do I empty the pool?
Is there, like, a...
Is there, like, a button?
Okay, well, I'll make sure he's clean.
Alright.
What if I just...
Okay, you are...
You're bothering me.
Okay, we're gonna...
Alright, we're gonna put all the bodies in here first.
Cause, like, it's...
It's very cluttered up right now.
So, we're gonna...
We're gonna put you...
We're just gonna put you in there.
Cause you're cluttering it up a little bit.
And I need to make sure...
How do I...
Wait.
UV light.
Why do I need to put UV light here?
I mean, I could tell...
I could see the blood.
I don't need a UV light.
Okay, so if I clean this, then, like...
I can't cancel the membership.
Why would you cancel, Tenjin?
I don't understand.
Aren't you a homie?
Why would you do that?
I'm here trying to clean.
I'm here to do...
Cleaning is so hard work and you're gonna cancel the membership?
Think about my dog!
Dexter!
And Doki, my real dog.
Think about my...
No!
This is your fault, Tenjin!
Look at that!
I fucking dropped my...
Look at what you did!
Now my hypothetical fake boss is gonna be so angry!
Okay.
Okay, it's all in the way.
I can't clear the way first.
It's not clear?
What is in the way?
You can't move like this.
What do you...
What's in the way?
There's nothing in the way!
What!
Okay.
Oh, it's like one wine bottle.
One fucking wine bottle.
Okay.
Okay, let's just... Alright.
It's okay, the water will clean the body up.
Shit, let's put this over here.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, now that... Oh shit, he's listening?
Boss, Big Jim, I would never do that to you, Big Jim.
Can I use the power washer?
Okay, now the power washer fucking sucks.
Yeah, this is his fault, honestly.
Okay, the power washer is so bad, I actually don't like the power washer.
I'm gonna... Wait, how do I put this away?
Okay.
Is this stronger now?
No, I feel like the power washer is not as good, I feel like.
It's so slow.
What's the nozzle change?
Oh, I can just go that way.
I mean, it's doing its job, I guess.
Yeah, it sort of is doing its job.
Everything sucks until it upgrades?
That's gotta... I need funding.
I need... That's why Big Jim believes in me.
He's gonna fund my cleaning... He's gonna be funding my cleaning, um, adventures.
And then I'm gonna be like the best janitor in the fucking city.
Guys, I got a sponsor.
Oh.
How do I put this away, then?
Uh...
How do I put this away?
Guys... Oh, there it is.
Okay, back to mob.
Mob time.
Oh, no.
Okay, we gotta go back to the bucket.
Alright.
Clean up.
Okay, I gotta clean up the mess I made because of Tenjin.
I got...
It's just out of water?
Yeah, but I feel like... I feel like the mob is stronger than the... I don't know.
I feel like the mob was just better than the, uh...
than the pressure for now.
Because the mob feels stronger.
Okay.
Clean, clean, clean.
I could add more water to it now.
There we go.
Oh, I did it!
Alright, might as well.
I mean, I do have it, so I might as well.
I gotta learn!
I gotta learn this new technology that all the... all the hip, uh... all the hip janitors use now.
I mean, it works, I guess.
Oh, I need to clean my footsteps too.
All the new janitors are using these new thingy technology.
Like the pressure washer.
So I might as well, like, get on with the times.
Yeah, I gotta get on with the times.
I can't just... I can't just always use my hands.
I have this technology.
Would you guys sponsor me to clean crime?
Guys, I need some sponsors so I can buy some new... so I can buy some new cleaning materials.
Guys, guys, if I don't, like, Big James is gonna fucking kill me.
I just don't want that.
Oh, this is for hard to reach places too.
Narcy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for... welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna learn.
We're gonna learn today regarding the power washer.
That is pretty handy.
Yeah, I actually like it.
Now that I, like, figured out how to use the power washer, I think I like it.
Okay.
There we go.
Did you guys know they're making a regular show sequel?
And an Adventure Time sequel?
And then somebody was talking about how, like...
I think it's, like, sort of true.
But, like... like, it's cool.
But then, like, the thing is...
The thing is that, like...
We're all just getting, like...
Re...
Recyc...
Like...
Like, it's just nostalgia bait.
And also, like, the new generation isn't getting new TV shows.
They're just getting our, like, hand-me-downs now.
Because nobody is, like...
No com...
No cartoon net...
Like, cartoon station is willing to, like, make new shows.
They're just, like...
Yeah.
They're, like, reheating the series and everything.
And I...
I sort of...
I, like...
I...
I think so, too.
Because I was, like...
Do we really...
Okay.
I feel like...
I feel like it just makes the show worse when you take...
When you re...
Reboot...
Like, reboot a series.
Or not just reboot, but add more episodes to a show that's already ended perfectly.
Because it's, like...
The voice actors are also getting older.
And they just don't sound the same.
I think the worst part is that, like, the voice actress for Marge Simpson...
She sounds like a dying cat now.
Because she's 80 years old.
The voice actress for Marge Simpson is 80 years old!
And she's...
Oh, my God.
She does not sound okay.
Like...
Because, like...
Oh, my God.
And...
No, no.
If you compare her voice now for Marge...
Versus her voice, like, before...
Like, her classic Marge Simpson voice...
It's actually, like...
Oh, my...
Let her retire, please!
Oh, my God.
It's just...
It's...
No!
Tenjin!
This is your fault!
This is your fault, Tenjin!
Okay.
Let me use this.
Why can't I...
Why can't I fucking...
Okay.
I'll clean that later.
Yeah.
And then, like...
And then, apparently, like, writers don't even know how to...
Why can't I use this?
No.
Okay.
Writers don't even know how to write endings anymore.
Because...
Because, like...
Wait.
Did I not refill?
No, I did.
Writers don't know how to write endings anymore.
Because every show gets canceled.
Every show gets canceled before it ends.
That's right.
The music knows I'm speaking my truth now.
Like...
Even the music knows I'm speaking my truth.
Yeah, they all, like...
I'm still...
Guys, no.
I'm still fucking upset that Inside Out got canceled.
That was such a good show.
Like, I was looking forward to more episodes of Inside Out, and then Netflix canceled it.
But Netflix is always canceling shows.
Which fucking sucks.
It was so good.
It was such a well-written show.
Inside Job.
Yeah, sorry.
Sorry.
There's two...
Inside Job.
The conspiracy theorist show.
It was such...
It was so good.
And then they canceled it after...
They canceled it after, like, two seasons.
Which fucking sucks.
Because it was actually really well-written, too.
And then I was really looking forward to more episodes of Inside Out.
But they were like, nope.
Nope.
We're canceling it.
All right.
Now we're listening to Ghibli.
Yay!
Okay.
Let's refill this.
Ba-bum.
Bum-bum.
Ba-da-dum.
Oh, it was even once...
Yeah, it was one season split into two.
You're right.
Yeah, that's worse.
Honestly.
I don't know.
I think that's even worse because it's not even, like, a full season.
It was just one season split into two.
Okay.
Let's get this out of the way.
We need to upgrade our...
We gotta upgrade a power washer.
Doesn't matter.
Honestly.
Like, who's gonna miss the...
Who's gonna miss the...
The wine?
All right.
Gotta clean this beautiful artwork.
We gotta make sure...
We gotta make sure this artwork is still there.
You're too far from the pressure washer.
Oh, whoops.
Squid Game is taking too much budget.
I just...
I don't understand why Squid Game needs a second season.
It was...
It...
Like, Squid Game, Squid Harder?
Like...
I don't know.
I feel like...
Like, what do you do?
We all know the premise of Squid Game.
They just...
They're just gonna redo the whole thing with new...
I guess it's sort of like Saw, where, like, we sort of know what the situation is like.
I don't know.
And, like, I don't know.
Saw...
Saw had a lot.
I also feel like it ended well enough that it did not need, like, a second season.
What is it?
Do you guys remember Handmaiden's Tale?
Like, the first two seasons, everybody was, like, super, super excited.
Like, people were talking about Handmaiden's Tale.
But then, like, they got out of, like...
And then I was like, what happened to Handmaiden's Tale?
You know?
Because, like, it's still ongoing.
Oh.
No, it's fine.
Like, who's gonna miss that anyway?
Like, it's...
It's fine.
Does it affect...
Do I lose money for breaking that vase?
Am I supposed to...
Oh, I might lose money.
Okay.
Whoops.
That's...
That's a little...
It can't be a legit China vase, right?
It cannot be from the Ming Dynasty, right?
I mean...
No.
This gotta be fake.
Why would you put that in the spa?
I lost 2K?
Is this coming out of my paycheck?
No!
My daughter is sick!
They won't...
Who would put a fucking expensive vase in the spa?
Like, that's just...
That just tells people to break it.
No!
Put this here for now.
Okay.
Put this here.
Alright.
It was broken already when I got here!
It was already broken!
You can't blame that on me!
Oh, there's another!
There's the women's bathroom.
Okay, this is actually closer.
Uuuuh.
I can't believe it!
Okay, let's put this in the women's...
Like, how would he know that that was already...
That wasn't broken already.
What was I talking about?
Before I was thinking about cleaning...
about the broken vase.
Okay, let's...
I guess we'll be delicate here.
Is there anything?
Oh, here it is.
Okay.
I mean, we can power wash with that.
Oh yeah, Squid Game.
It's like... okay, Handmaiden's Tale.
Yeah, I was saying about Handmaiden's Tale.
The thing about...
And then I was like...
Oh, what happened to that show?
Are they still being trapped in the tale?
Are the ladies still trapped?
And then they're apparently...
in Canada now.
I was like, what?
They're in Canada and trying...
to do a revolt.
So they're not...
trapped anymore.
And then apparently the show got worse...
because of the fact that...
the fact that...
it got less interesting.
Not because they're in Canada.
Like...
It's not because...
It's because they escaped.
So they're like, what do we do with the story now?
So now the story is that they're trying to...
overthrow the government and stuff.
But then it got...
boring.
Apparently it got really boring.
I think the funniest thing about the show...
is the fact that one of the actresses...
is a Scientologist.
So...
I don't know.
I think...
It's pretty ironic.
Like one of the lead actresses...
is a fucking Scientologist.
So I thought that was like...
super ironic that they're in The Handmaid's Tale.
Like...
Yeah!
I don't remember what her name was.
But she was one of the main actresses.
Oh shit.
That's okay.
I'll clean that later.
Oh no!
My power washer!
It's okay.
Let's see.
Okay, we're just gonna clean this.
Oh, so that's how they...
they did the killing.
They got an ice pick.
God, why can't...
As a janitor, I should just have like...
a pet pig around me.
You know pigs eat blood?
Or like drink blood?
And like, it's okay.
There's no like health concerns for it too.
In anything.
If I'm gonna be a crime scene...
Yeah, they eat anything.
They eat bone.
They eat blood.
They can drink blood.
Basically, the reason why I was like...
If I'm gonna be a crime scene killer...
I should have a pet pig.
Is that you can literally get a pig...
and just clean up the entire thing.
Because that's food!
And you don't need to feed the pig!
Yeah, they eat each other.
So like...
If a pig gets injured...
They separate the pig from the other...
The injured pig from the other pigs.
Because if a pig has a scratch...
and starts bleeding...
The other pigs will fucking eat that pig.
Because they see it as food.
Which is pretty fucked up, but welcome to nature I guess.
Like...
It's fucked up, but the circle of life, baby.
And then someone was saying...
It's a silly bone.
Yeah, but bone is easier to dispose of.
Like I don't have to clean the blood anymore.
I can literally just like...
Pick up the bone and like...
I can just pick up the bone.
And just...
Put it in a trash can.
Like I'm already disposing the bodies.
But now it's like less work.
Because then I can just...
Get like 10 pigs here.
Get 10 pigs.
And then like go wild.
Oh, they eat the bones too.
Get 10 pigs in here.
Go fucking wild.
Eat the bones.
Don't have to worry about biological waste.
And then like...
Just gotta take care of 10 pigs.
And then you know...
After the 10 pigs...
You know, and if the 10 pigs...
Get old, eat the pigs.
Free food.
That's free food right there.
Alright, we got the ice pick evidence.
Okay, we don't have to worry about that.
Wait, what?
How do I...
How do I get...
Oh, is it this?
Uh...
What?
Oh!
Oh, I see.
Okay.
This is easy.
Okay, I can just...
Oh, it gets rid of my health for that.
Okay, this is easy.
Professor Jason!
Oh, hey.
Everything I say is hypothetical.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Mr. Lawyer.
Everything I say is all hypothetical.
It's a game.
We're all just...
It's all hypothetical, sir.
Oh, money.
My hypothetical money, by the way.
In -game money.
I forgot about things.
Water up, water down?
The fuck does that mean?
Oh, I cleaned the water!
Wait, that's that easy?
And now the water's clean!
Okay.
Okay, let's...
Wait, how do I...
Okay.
Okay, I gotta get rid of this.
I gotta get rid of the water here.
Alright.
Let's see.
Okay, so...
Now that...
Okay, I need to get my pressure thing here.
I'll refill it first before I clean the inside of the pool.
Alright.
You still got blood?
Yeah, but it's just a little blood.
Okay.
Um, we'll keep the bodies in here.
This is like my body room.
My body hole.
So we'll put that here, and then we'll pressure... Oh shit!
It's fine.
You won't miss that.
That was already... Like, when they were committing the murders, I'll just say, like, the bodies...
The bodies were fully dead when you stabbed him.
And then they moved around a little bit.
And then after they moved around, they broke those glasses.
Like...
Like, how would he know?
How would he know?
It's like...
It's glasses you can get at a fucking dollar store.
It's literally one dollar.
It's not that important, guys.
It's one dollar glasses.
It's...
Like...
It's one dollar glass... I bet it's not even glass.
I bet it's a plastic cup.
I bet it's a plastic cup I can get for 50 cents.
What are they recording?
There's no way.
There's no way they're recording this.
There's no sound in...
Like, there's no sound in, like...
In, like, recording cameras.
Alright.
Wipe all the blood.
Okay.
Whoops.
That's another plastic...
Guys, you can tell that cup is plastic with the way...
Look, as long as I don't break the...
I don't break the expensive whiskey, then it's fine.
Then it's five dollars.
See?
I didn't break the whiskey.
It's fine.
Yeah, from the... I can literally go to Daiso and grab the same cup.
Can I break this?
Oh, so that's fucking strong.
Oh shit, that's a gun.
That's...
Okay.
This is pretty relaxing.
It helps that I'm listening to Ghibli while doing this.
Okay,
nice.
More plastic cups.
Whoops.
It's fine.
Alright.
It's not the whiskey, right?
Guys, that's fine.
That's fine.
We'll just say that in their dying breath, they knocked some things away.
That's okay.
We still have this bottle of whiskey, guys.
We're fine.
We still...
We still have this bottle of whiskey.
We're fine.
I keep making a better mess.
But at least it's clean.
At least it's clean.
That's all that matters.
It's at least clean.
Oh shit!
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Oh, we need a pool gun.
It's like a little water gun.
I'm gonna clean this area first before...
Alright, I'm gonna make sure this area is fine too.
Alright...
...
Okay, we're gonna grab this.
Another one.
And then, what else is there?
Okay, it's just a body so I can just clean the pool.
You're right.
I'll charge the build attention.
That's how we're gonna get away with it.
It's like almost good as new, chat.
We just need to make sure there's no body here and it's almost good as new.
Alright, refill time.
Refill time.
Oh, our playlist is almost over.
Alright, any suggestions for music to listen to?
Best calming music to listen to?
Guys, it has to be good cleaning music, guys.
It has to...
It has to be good cleaning music, guys.
We already listened to a Minecraft...
Oh!
I know.
Pokemon Jazz.
Or Lo-Fi.
Maybe Jazz or Lo-Fi.
An orchestra mix?
Oh, that's good.
Here we go.
Thanks, we have an orchestra mix too.
Yay!
I don't recognize this song.
Where the fuck is that from?
Is this from the newer games?
That can't be Pokemon!
That's not the Pokemon I know!
What the fuck is that?
Is that...
Is that the newest one?
It could be.
I was like, what song is that?
I don't even recognize it.
But it's good.
Yeah, but I can't relate because I don't recognize it.
How am I supposed to relate to it if I don't recognize it, chat?
Oh, there's smooth jazz.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I recognize this.
Bum, bum, bum.
Oh, I know this.
Ooh.
You like jazz?
Okay, I didn't break anything.
Alright, we're gonna get rid of the blood here.
Yes, we're black and white!
I recognize this one.
Okay, there's a little blood here, so I gotta clean this part too.
It's so relaxing.
It's crazy how music can just change the vibe of the game.
Okay, we gotta clean this.
There's a spot in a...
Okay, let me grab my lamp.
I think it's easier if I have my lamp.
Okay.
Where is it?
Oh, no!
There's no spot here.
Everything is clean.
Okay, there's like one up here.
Uh, and there's some here.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
I guess I can...
Okay, let's clean the chair first.
No, my lamp!
Fuck.
Uh, it's fine.
I can see all the mess anyway.
It's fine.
I see where the mess is.
And then now I can use my mop, I think.
Just to get the...
the hard to get spots.
Okay, I think that's good.
Anything else?
Okay, we'll grab this here.
I wonder where the secrets are.
Is that everything?
Oh, there's my feet.
How did I cause such a big mess here?
How did I do that?
Okay.
Oh no.
Oh wait, no.
It still works.
Oh, it doesn't work anymore.
Push my hands.
Okay, now it should be clean.
Okay, I gotta make sure I clean the...
where I spilled my...
where I spilled it.
I don't even know where the secrets are.
Is it in the women's bathroom?
Oh, this one's locked.
Oh, there's money.
Would these be the secrets?
Oh my god, Rome is very popular.
Where are the...
dead ladies?
Why is there only dead men?
I need to open it from the other side.
Oh, I need to open it from this side.
Okay.
Science tip.
Hydrogen peroxide and sulfuric acid dissolves...
Oh, I learned that from Breaking Bad!
But it takes like a really long time to do it.
So you might as well just get a pig.
That's what I'm saying.
Why go through all that trouble?
Why go through all that trouble dissolving a body if you just get a pig?
It's just that much more convenient.
IMO.
Okay, let's grab...
Let's destroy...
Let's get rid of all the garbage here that was already...
By the way, that was here already, by the way, guys.
The trash was always here.
Remember that.
It was here when I...
when I got here.
Like, I can't believe it.
When you're committing murder, at least clean up the murder.
Just clean up a little bit.
Support your janitors.
Putting so much work onto me to clean this up for them.
Toki operates on pig physics.
It's just more convenient.
The only issue is that you gotta take care of the pigs.
But like, if the pigs are too hard to take care of, just rent some pigs.
Rent some pigs and like take it back to the farm after you're done.
And then the farmers don't have to spend money on pig food.
I'll just be like, can I rent a pig for a day and I'll pay for the...
I'll pay for its meals.
What about the people who like...
Well, the pigs have to poop.
Yeah, but there's not...
People won't know they're dead bodies.
They won't know.
What's it gonna do?
Poop blood?
No, it won't.
It's just regular...
What are they gonna do?
Examine the poop?
Who has the time to do that?
I would not get caught.
Like, I'm safe.
I can't get... I will not get caught.
I'm still fucking making content right now.
Sir...
Okay, we gotta get rid of this.
Okay, we gotta get rid of this evidence.
So this is the true form of the...
True form of the tomato fire.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All true.
Oh my god, did they use a pizza cutter to...
to kill that guy?
Oh!
They used a pizza cutter for fucking slicing the throat?
Holy shit, that guy had some fun.
That guy had a lot of fun.
Is that all the trash?
Is there any more?
I don't think so.
I think I got all the trash.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, well...
Okay, I got all the trash, so...
Let's do some basketball.
Watch this.
Okay, wait.
I didn't know the range.
There we go.
Look at that.
Fucking...
Kobe!
Oh, shit.
Oh, wait!
Nice.
Game logic.
Kobe!
Oh.
Wait, why is it going down?
I'm throwing up!
There we go.
Easy.
It just works.
Oh, I see.
Oh, if I hold it.
If I hold it, it goes further.
See?
Look at that.
Why does that pizza cutter have a crosscard?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Speaking of pizzas, I was so mad.
Okay, not mad.
I was so annoyed.
Because, like, um...
Yesterday, I had a huge craving for pizza.
So, I was like, oh, what kind...
I was turning up at four in the morning because I went...
I took a nap.
Um, I took a nap and, like, I ended up waking up at two in the morning.
So I didn't have dinner or anything.
So, I was like, oh, I want pizza.
So, the only places that were open at that time was, like, pizza and burgers and stuff.
So, I was like, you know what?
I'm going to get some pizza.
And then they were doing, like, this promotion where it was like, buy one, get one...
Uh...
It was broken when I got here, guys.
It was broken when I got here.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Anyway, as I was saying...
Oh wait, it wouldn't matter if I use the mob.
There's no fragile stuff here.
Anyway, it said it was selected pizzas.
But the pizzas I wanted was not in the selected pizzas.
So I got really confused.
I was like, okay, I really want to order these two pizzas.
But it's not part of the promotion.
So I was like, okay, I'm going to order two pizzas.
Because I really wanted those two specific pizzas.
Okay, it'll be fine.
If I spill it, right?
Oh, it refills it.
And then I got a pepperoni pizza and a spicy pizza.
Because I wanted some spice, too.
They didn't have the...
Okay, there's this specific pizza that I really like these days.
It's very specific.
It's like pepperoni with hot honey.
I don't know if you guys ever had it.
But it's basically pepperoni pizza.
But with a kick in it.
With the hot honey.
And it's so good.
It's like really, really, really good.
So it's just like...
It adds like a sweet and spice to it.
I highly suggest trying it out.
It's actually really, really fucking good.
And then like...
But the thing is, the pizza place I wanted to order didn't have hot honey.
So I was like, all right.
Then...
And so I was like, all right.
So I'm going to get...
I'll just separate...
Or there's some spicy pizza and hot honey.
And pepperoni.
And then like, you know, try the slices out.
And so I was like...
So I ordered two pizzas.
And then the guy brought me four fucking boxes of pizza.
And I was like, what?
He's like, so...
Yeah, so I went to collect it.
And then he's like, yeah, there's a lot.
There's four boxes.
And I was like, excuse me?
Like...
So like, apparently the pizza store has a special promotion for all the pizzas.
I didn't know.
It literally said, these are the pizzas that are buy one get one free.
So I was like, well, I don't really want those pizzas.
I want this specific one.
And then so I got four fucking...
I got four boxes of pizzas.
I don't know what to...
I don't know what to do.
I...
Oh, that's...
Oh, I forgot about this lady.
I forgot she existed.
Oh, whoops.
Okay.
Whoops.
We gotta...
Yeah, I don't...
Now I have four boxes of pizzas that I have to finish in like, I don't know, three to four days.
Oh, shit.
That's a lot of blood.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's really hard to clean.
I'm gonna get the pressure washer in here.
Okay.
So that's where the 86% was.
Oh, my God.
Like, why is your blood so difficult to clean?
I don't understand.
Your blood should...
Oh, is it because it's got microwave?
Is it because of microwave?
It's microwave blood.
So it's a harder stain.
That must be it.
Is it obvious what to do?
You feel...
Yeah, he feeds the pigs.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, this lady died by tanning.
I was like thinking, like, how do you...
How's your blood stains if you like, if you just got like heated to death?
Like, it's not like you got squashed or anything.
Like, I don't understand.
Any like, any like criminologist in chat can tell me like the science behind dying by a tanner.
Cause like...
Oh, she popped.
Oh, because of like the heat pressure.
So she popped like a popcorn.
I get it.
Oh, so like the heat pressure expanded her and she popped like a popcorn.
I see.
I was just thinking if you get microwaved, how is their blood?
Why is it so difficult to clean?
God.
If you're gonna...
Like, just shoot her.
I feel like just shooting her would have been like so much easier.
And less messier.
I guess like they wanted to be fancy with their kill.
If you kill for a living, you get bored eventually.
So you start being fancy with it just to have like some spice in that life.
Cause like, you know, you gotta be...
It must be like really monotonous if you're like...
Monotonous if you're like just killing.
For a job.
And like...
And then like, you know, you get bored eventually.
If you just, you know, if you just pop, pop.
Or just one singular pop.
And you just want to feel something.
You're like, you know, let's get a little creative with it.
Do I change it?
Yeah, gotta change it up every now and then.
You know?
How do I free her from the tanner?
Oh, there she is.
Alright, don't worry.
Oh my god.
She fucking popped her hair too?
Get in there.
What happened to her hair?
You can't just microwave hair away.
Can you?
Oh shit, wait, that's the lockers.
Wait.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Okay, so these are all...
Yoink, yoink.
They're dead.
It's not...
It's not evil if they're dead already.
It burned off?
That can happen?
Wait, how do you guys know that?
Like...
Wait a minute.
How...
How do you guys know that?
Huh?
Sigh.
Oh!
There's a VIP.
Hey, there's basketball.
Okay, we gotta grab...
Yoink, yoink.
Let's put the basketball back.
Oh shit, did I kill a basketball player?
Did you guys hear about Logan Paul and KSI sending, like, fucking 10...
Like, was it a shitload of Prime to, like, the people from the...
From people who...
Who needed the Prime?
Who needed, like, water?
I thought that was funny because they could literally have sent water, but then they sent Prime.
I...
I don't understand.
Like, I feel like if they sent water, it'll be better publicity.
Like, why...
I...
I don't understand.
Like, this is so funny.
I was like...
Like, it's like...
I...
I get it.
Like, well, that's, like, a really nice thing to do, but, like, why did they fucking send Prime?
Like...
Like, would it have helped their publicity so much if they literally just sent...
It'd be cheaper!
Like...
I guess they're like, oh, if we send them Prime instead of water because they're, like, apparently, like, it's, like, a really hard...
They haven't been in...
I can sort of understand it because they're like, oh, what if we get these people hooked onto Prime because there's no water in the city.
There's literally, like, no water in the city.
So, like...
And apparently, it's, like, a really hard to reach place so that, like, other natural, like, necessity supplies can't get there.
So, they are forced to drink Prime for, like, for, like, water, you know, to not die from dehydration.
But then, like...
So, then they're, like...
I guess, like, their thinking is that, oh, we can get them addicted to Prime, you know, during a hurricane, by the way.
During...
Like...
I just...
It's just a little...
It's a little fucked.
Like...
The thinking...
Well...
Like, after the hurricane is over and they're back in their life, like, back to, like, normal society, they're like, oh, I'm gonna drink Prime because I'm addicted to Prime now.
Or, like...
Like, whoa.
Like...
Yeah, it's...
It's...
I don't know.
Like, their motto is that, like, any publicity is good publicity.
Which is crazy to think about.
Like...
Like, so many things has happened to KSI and Logan Paul.
And, like...
And they get away with...
I...
I don't...
I don't understand.
They're, like...
They...
They're so many things.
Yeah, they are!
There's...
They still have an audience.
Oh, my God.
Guys, if KSI and Logan Paul fans are gonna come into my...
Guys, I don't know if I should start...
Like, they're gonna be like, who's this fucking P and G trying to start a fight with me?
You're not even real.
Like...
Guys, it would be so funny, though, if, like, KSI...
Like, KSI would be like, oh, I'm gonna...
Oh, my God, Logan Paul acknowledged me for trying to fight them.
Like...
It wasn't real to us.
I just can't believe.
I thought that shit was so crazy.
That shit was so crazy.
Like, literally, they're like, we're gonna send Prime.
Like, a fucking truckload of Prime.
To the people.
Like...
To the people that need water.
And I'm like, just send water.
Just...
Just send water.
Fado, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello, Doki.
I've been watching you since your glorious return.
And you're always the highlight.
Also, it's my birthday.
Can I humbly ask for a happy birthday?
Of course.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Fado.
Where's the last blood?
I have, like, a 98% left.
Oh, my God.
I have a great birthday.
That it?
No, I'm still at 98.
What else do I have?
Oh, okay.
It's, like, right here.
It's, like, a hard to reach spot.
98?
What else?
Where is the last drop?
Oh, shit.
That's not what I want.
Okay.
Let's, like, turn on.
We're gonna bring this.
Get this over here.
How do I?
Okay.
Do I need blood?
Do I need doko?
Blood doko?
Johnny Lacone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait.
Is there blood in here?
No.
This should be the office.
Didn't Logan Paul get sued by a manufacturer of Prime because they backed order too much Prime?
They just sticked to a product and refused to pay due to not being able to sell?
Wait.
Is that true?
I didn't know that.
Oh, there's so many.
Oh, maybe it's this.
There's so many things that happen with, like, Logan Paul and KSI.
I can't keep track of it anymore.
Like...
There's so many stuff.
Like, it's so hard to keep track of it.
Because they get away with so much that, like, I don't even know anymore.
Okay.
Everything seems clean.
Oh, like each room is different.
I see.
I mean it's like 98%.
It's like almost perfect.
Oh, it's here.
The back side of the chair.
Okay, now it's 99.
Maybe it's like the back side of this chair?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Wait, really?
Oh, yeah!
I did it!
Nice!
Alright, let's see.
Whoops.
Now I just got to dispose of this.
Now it's time to play basketball.
I get over here.
Alright.
Nice!
Alright, this is the trash.
Y'all is in the trash!
Nice.
Alright.
Whoops.
Boom.
He's dead already.
It's fine.
Alright.
Time to eat this corpse out too.
In you go!
No!
It was so close!
Can I punch it over?
Nice.
Okay.
Alright, that's convenient.
That's convenient.
Oops, sorry.
That was intentional.
Alright.
In you go!
Boop!
Oh, come on!
Here we go.
I'm not actually sorry.
Oops, sorry!
Alright.
In you go!
God damn it!
Guys, I know like...
This is not intentional.
I'm just too lazy.
There we go.
I'm too lazy to pick him up again.
It's just more convenient to just chuck...
punch him forward.
It's literally just more convenient, guys.
Nice.
Alright, so...
I have 95%?
Where's the blood?
It says 95% but like, where's the blood?
Where is it?
There's literally nothing here.
I don't understand.
No, it's like in here.
Oh, it's in here!
Oh!
Then it has to be...
Where could it be then?
Where could the last remaining be?
Oh, there...
No, that's not it.
Wait, where's my UV light?
Oh, no?
Where did I put my UV light?
Is it the sink?
No?
Where did I put my light?
Where the fuck is it?
Guys, I can't find my UV light.
I don't know where I put it.
Okay, we'll have this.
No, that's just a regular light.
Guys, thank you for the super chat!
Oh, you got into medical school!
Congratulations!
Look at that chat!
I told you we had smart dragoons!
I fucking told you guys!
I knew it.
I always knew we had smart dragoons here.
But they say chat reflects the streamer.
Where could the blood be?
Is it the mirror?
I think that's just regular fluids.
Yeah.
It's literally just regular fluids.
See?
He can read!
I fucking knew it.
If I can read, he can read.
95% Like, this is fully clean.
No, it's...
Oh, shit.
95% is actually a very high percentage for blood.
No one will know.
It's fine.
I'm too lazy.
Guys, all I'm saying is that if they wanted a five star clean, they would have hired two people.
Not just one.
There's literally nothing in here.
Like, if they want a better job of cleaning, it would have been two people.
Like, they hired one so they cheapened out.
Floor near door?
Okay.
That's all I'm saying.
They cheapened out.
Check the flower pot in the building.
That was bloody.
No, the flower pot is okay.
In the changing room closet?
There's a closet?
Oh, shit.
I would there to be like, okay, if there's blood in here, it's not because of fucking...
It's not because of murder.
It's literally that it could be somebody's time of the month.
Like, does it really matter?
If it's in the bathroom, it's not because of murder.
Holy shit, the Anubis actually scared me.
I thought it was like...
Oh, my God.
I legitimately thought that was like...
I thought that was like a person.
Yep, I'm cleaning murder stains.
I'm cleaning fucking murder stains.
Not because I'm like...
I'm not a real janitor.
I'm here to clean blood.
Okay.
Alright, this is 99%.
The fuck is...
Okay, I'm not here.
It doesn't have to be perfect at that point.
If it's 99%, then fuck that shit.
Okay, that's it.
It's alright.
Yeah, but then it won't be suspicious blood?
It won't be suspicious blood.
It's just regular blood.
Where does the VIP access go to?
Wait.
Yeah, exactly.
I killed 99%... Oh, there it is.
99% blood.
Oh, hey.
What happens in here?
Oh, calligraphy?
I mean, like...
Okay.
Oh, no!
Not just calligraphy.
Intense calligraphy.
It's hardcore calligraphy.
Imagine doing powder and then fucking doing calligraphy after.
Like...
Alright, nice.
We got the...
Oh, nice.
All this extra cash.
Calligraphy.
Advanced calligraphy.
Things get pretty intense.
You don't understand with the powder.
Things get...
Things get pretty fucking intense with calligraphy after that.
The powder helps it lock in.
It's so fucking locked in after that.
Okay.
Oh my god.
He mixed alcohol in it too.
That shit's intense.
Interior design is my passion.
That is intense calligraphy.
Okay.
Um...
Where would the flower pot be?
I guess like... Oh!
Wait, can I steal the rubber ducky?
I want my daughter to get some rubber duckies.
Alright, we're gonna collect this rubber ducky.
Okay.
Where does this go?
Oh.
No, that's not where it goes.
Wait, where does this go?
Okay.
That goes here.
It's nice that I've got some screwdrivers with me too.
Where's the other thing?
Oh, there it is.
I was gonna say.
I swear I have another table.
Okay, where's the other chair?
Oh, there it is.
No.
That's not it.
Okay, if we put this vase over here, it's almost like there's nothing missing.
See?
Look at that.
Okay, we gotta...
Okay, this vase...
If we put this vase here...
And then...
This vase over here...
Guys, I know it's different sizes, but like, I don't think people would notice.
I don't...
Guys, they won't notice.
How would they know?
Okay, this goes here.
And then this goes here.
Is that it?
Where's my other chair?
This chair?
Where the fuck did the other chair go?
Oh, wait.
Nice.
Why is there a suitcase here?
Oh, nice.
Okay, I'm gonna take the suitcase.
This might be an important suitcase.
You don't know that.
There we go.
Oh, it's this chair!
I thought it fit the environment.
It looked so...
It literally fits so well.
What am I missing?
Oh, wait.
Oh, nice.
Everything I touch turns to gold, turns to coal, turns then to rust, then to dust.
Nice memes.
Okay.
What else?
I'm missing some more?
I'm missing two furnitures.
Where?
Is it the flat?
Is it the rubber duck?
Oh, it's the rubber duckies!
Oh!
Okay.
That has to be it, right?
Is it the rubber duckies?
Oh.
Whoops.
Guys, it was not the rubber duckies, guys.
Where does this flower go?
Where...
Why is my ego vision working?
On top of the meadow...
Oh, is it here?
No, it doesn't.
Oh, my God.
This wall...
This weird wall of shit is gonna...
I'm gonna go crazy.
Oh, wait!
No!
I can't grab it!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
It must be a way.
Oh, no!
I can't!
Oh, I got it!
I fucking got it!
I actually got it!
Oh, thank God.
Okay, we're fine.
Okay.
I thought I burnt it forever.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
It's fine.
Okay, we got it.
We fixed everything.
Okay, we did it.
Yay!
The trash?
There's 1% of trash?
Is it this?
No.
Why is there so trash?
Where the fuck is the last trash?
Oh, my God.
Are you serious?
How...
What do you mean?
Where the fuck...
It's like 1.
It's like...
It's literally 1 trash.
Okay, it's...
Get rid of the trash.
It's literally 99%.
Oh, my God.
What?
Is that it?
Is that trash?
Oh, it's just... Oh, wait.
It's money.
Wait, that's better than trash.
This is better...
Oh, my God.
This is better than trash.
Nice.
Where the fuck is that 1%?
Oh, my God.
I swear to God.
I'm gonna go fucking crazy, like...
I still have evidence, too?
Oh, it's this.
Okay, nice.
Rockefeller Records?
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Bum, bum, bum.
Oh, my God.
No wonder he fucking died.
Oh,
my God.
My mom.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
Oh, no wonder he fucking died.
Bro, say his crap.
I'm making it out of the hood.
Oh, damn.
That's fucked.
But true.
So true.
I don't know where the last trash is, guys.
I'm gonna go fucking crazy.
The one last trash.
Is that it?
Is that it over there?
It's like... Oh, my God.
It's literally in the pool.
Oh, my God.
It's right here.
I can't even... Okay, there we go.
We did it.
We cleaned it up.
All right.
Thank God.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Oh, it's fine.
It says task completed.
All right.
We did it.
I'll finish it.
And I'll be able to...
Guys, 5% is fine.
They won't notice.
If they won a better job, they would have hired two people.
Look.
100%.
Look at that.
Perfect score.
The mob does not really care about...
The mob doesn't care about the details, guys.
If they cared about the details...
What's his name?
Was it Al Capone?
Al Capone wouldn't have got busted for tax reasons if they cared about the details.
Oh, nice.
Perfect.
Yay.
Can't deny that.
That's why they should care.
Look.
That's not my fault.
I'm not the mob.
I'm just a contractor.
Al Capone was fishing his own swimming pool at the end.
Al Capone?
It's fucking... Okay.
Wait.
There's two secrets.
What the fuck is the secret?
Okay.
Al Capone?
Like...
I don't know if you guys know this, but there were actual parasites in his brain in the end, guys.
Like he was not okay.
What is the fucking clink?
Oh my god.
Oh, I found him.
Are you a...
Good boy.
Yeah, his brain got like actual...
Yeah, he got... Guys, if he cared about details, he would not have got syphilis.
The clapping never stops.
Oh no.
The fucking clapping.
Yay.
Crime.
Oh my god.
I'm going crazy.
I'm fucking going crazy.
I...
Oh my god.
I'm going...
I'm gonna go fucking crazy with this.
Stop!
Okay.
Increase all stats.
I'm gonna put it all onto... Oh my god.
Please.
Why is it clapping?
Okay.
Where's my bed?
Where the fuck is... Okay, there's my bed.
Oh my god.
The clap.
The clapping don't stop.
Alright.
I think this is a good... Oh wait.
I think this is a good place to call it here.
I didn't realize there was a story.
I thought I was just gonna clean... I thought I was just gonna clean some prime... some fucking prime.
That's interesting that there's a story in there.
I mean, it's pretty comfy too.
It's a really comfy game.
When you have like the right music for it.
Like...
When you have...
When you have the right music to go along with the...
with the game.
It gets really comfy.
Um... Oh my god.
That was really fun.
I really enjoyed it.
Um... I've been meaning to play...
I was like thinking about either like Power Wash Simulator or... or Crime Scene Cleaner.
So I'm glad I went with Crime Scene Cleaner.
I had a really good time playing the game.
I hope you guys do too.
Um...
I... Do you know what?
I'm gonna do something crazy guys.
You guys know what I'm gonna do?
We haven't done this in a long time.
We're gonna...
We're gonna do...
Donation reading time.
Oh my god.
It's been years.
But I'm feeling it today.
Oh my god.
I'm feeling it today.
We're gonna actually read all the Super Chats today guys.
Um... Alright.
Let's go from the very beginning.
Let me...
Move all the way.
Fan funding.
Um...
Micah, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Get well soon.
Dad.
Well...
He doesn't need to get well soon.
It's more so of like...
Uh...
You know... He needs to...
Oh, Sonia saved my name.
He just needs to live with it.
Like... That's really it.
He just has to live with it because of his allergies.
So like...
There's no get well.
He's just...
It's like... Survive.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Andy!
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Doki on the Smartphone.
New York Mets Playoff.
Baseball on the TV.
A great evening.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Ghost Rider.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Ivan.
Why does Dad have the infinity stones of allergies?
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
It's just purebreds.
Um... Like...
Yeah, the... You get like a fancier dog.
Like... Okay.
The worst part is that you pay more to have a more fucked up dog.
So like... I think that's a little... That's like... Where it's... You know...
A little...
That's the concern here.
That's the...
And it's like...
It's not just like wiener dogs.
It's like every type of breed.
Because... Yes, the genetics you're getting are purebred.
But like... The thing about like... If we look at history... Um...
If we look at history...
Um... You know, like real people.
Like... What's his name?
King Tut.
From like...
In the... From the Egypt times.
Like...
Yeah, like... He...
He's like really famous in Egyptian history.
But he had a lot of genetic issues.
Like... Because his like... His family line were just brothers and sisters.
Banging each other to keep the line royal.
And apparently he had like a lot of fucking issues.
And that's why he died really really young.
Because the inbreeding was so fucking bad.
Um...
Um... So we take that and apply it to dogs.
Uh... Because we're like... We wanna have this specific dog breed.
Like they're like...
So like wiener dogs...
Um... Have like a lot of issues.
In the point where like... You know... Uh...
Uh... You can get cases where like... You know...
They're more likely to be allergic to life.
Because of their...
Uh... Because of the genetic freak that they are.
Cause dogs aren't supposed to be that long.
Dogs... Dogs aren't supposed to be that long.
But then we are like... But they're so cute.
So... Look how tiny they are.
And how long they are.
Like...
And then you're just like... They were bred to hunt badgers in holes.
And that's why they're... Okay.
I don't understand why they're that long.
Like...
They can literally be like...
They don't have to be that long to hunt badgers.
They just have to be that short.
Um... So like...
Yes.
I'm part of the problem.
I'm part of the problem cause I still bought a wiener dog.
But I... I still...
At least I didn't buy a pug.
Cause that's the biggest... Like pugs are like... Even.
worse.
But like...
There's a reason... They're really short because they have to be that short to chase badgers out.
And that's why they're short.
But I don't understand the long part.
But like they look cute when they're long.
So like... Um...
So that's why like usually purebred dogs have like a whole lot of issues.
Because like to keep them pure, genetically there's something wrong.
Like...
Oh yeah.
Golden...
Golden retrievers have hip issues.
Like...
There's a lot.
You're supposed to be...
The more diverse...
The more mixed breeding you do...
The healthier the dog is.
Or like animals in general.
The healthier the animal is if you like mix the breeds up.
Because of the genetic diversity that comes into it.
So like... But we don't do that because we're like that's not cute.
So...
We're the problem here.
Um...
We're the problem.
Cause we're like but that's not cute.
So...
Sometimes they can be cute.
Sometimes they can be cute and then they create a new type of breed.
But there's sometimes there's some types of dogs that are like you should not mix them together.
Because it's just not it.
Like it's just...
It's just not it.
Like...
There's some dog breeds out there where I was like oh...
I don't know why.
Like...
It's just not it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey don't diss my little Cavapoos.
What the fuck is a Cavapoo?
What the fuck?
Oh those!
I don't like those types of dog breeds.
I'm...
Okay.
The reason why is that them and Toy Poodles...
I see them... It was like a huge thing in Asia.
So I saw them everywhere.
Like everybody I knew owned either that or a Toy Poodle.
Like it looked exactly like that.
It was everywhere.
Like nobody owned any other dog.
Like it was literally that or Toy Poodles.
And I was like... I was so tired of seeing those fucking dogs.
And like...
I know it's not their fault.
But I was so fucking tired of seeing those dogs.
I was just like...
It was just everywhere.
There's no other dog.
It was just those breeds.
Because they're like really popular on social media.
They're really popular in social media.
So everybody owns one.
Like everybody I knew who had a dog owned one.
And then like I would like walk around like walking my wiener dog.
And then like I just see those dogs and they're just everywhere.
I'm just... There was no diversity.
There was just no diversity in dogs.
Um...
Uh...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At this rate he'll get into YouTubers.
Be careful Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thoughts on Deerhead Chihuahua aka the non-ugly Chihuahua.
There's a non-ugly version of a Chihuahua?
What does it look like?
Ugh.
Sorry.
Um...
I mean...
It's a dog.
Like a...
It's just... It's like a Chihuahua but it's eyes aren't bulging out.
But like it's still...
To me it's still a Chihuahua.
Like...
Um... Like...
I feel like... Yeah.
It's eyes don't look like it's about to pop out of it's fucking head but it has everything else still of a Chihuahua.
That like is not...
I just don't like Chihuahuas in general.
That's my personal opinion.
Like I just don't like Chihuahuas.
I feel like...
Like they're just little menaces.
Like...
Um...
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Um...
King Charles II of Spain baffled Christian by continuing to live.
Also, there are people trying to breed pugs with other breeds to restore their genome.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I heard about that.
Oh, I know about King Charles.
He's the one with the crooked jaw, right?
Yeah, this guy.
This guy.
I heard about him.
People were like...
He was supposed to die.
But then he survived.
He had... He was like...
He was like...
Really... And then apparently the painting of him was supposed to make him look good.
Because like...
He was, you know...
Paintings are supposed to make people look better.
So this was like...
His... This was a painting that was like...
Sort of like... His good side.
Although like... There's not really a lot to go off of.
But... Um... He had...
Okay, let me look read up.
I remember reading about him.
King Charles 2.
He had like...
A lot of stuff going on.
But he was apparently a really nice guy.
He was a very nice guy.
He was just, you know... Genetically.
He was like... Just...
Yeah...
He was...
There was a lot going on.
But...
But he was apparently...
Like genetically... What was genetically wrong?
How do I look that up?
Genetically wrong King Charles 2?
Alright.
That was caused by inbreeding.
Based on research suggests... What does he have?
I know he had like...
Brain issues too.
But I don't remember... Oh yeah!
He can't walk.
So he had to use like braces.
To walk.
And then...
He...
He was extremely active physically.
Well at least he had that.
He can't walk.
But at least he was active.
Like...
What the fuck?
He spent... Sometimes he spent sleeping with his father's body?
Oh!
Oh...
Like done under doctor's advice that would help him produce... Oh and he can't produce an air.
Yeah!
Yeah...
Yeah... He's like a liger.
You know?
Cause like ligers are infertile.
Because genetically... Genetically like... They're so fucked up.
They're infertile.
If you mix breeds too much...
So you forced a breed to mix.
They're not... They're not fertile.
So like... He's just a liger.
But like not...
Not like as good looking.
No.
Ligers are pretty fucked up.
They're like way too big.
And like...
I don't think ligers look that good.
For those who don't know what liger is.
It's when you crossbreed a lion and a tiger together.
And then you get a...
A lion-tiger genetic mess.
And you cat... Ligers... Technically ligers...
A male liger is infertile.
A male liger...
Cannot be... Cannot be used to make more ligers.
But a female liger can make more...
I guess they're not ligers anymore.
But a female liger can breed with a lion or a tiger.
So then you can get that type of genetic mess.
I don't know why I know this.
Like...
Fun facts with Doki.
Sharko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why does King Charles look like a VTuber model?
Don't say that about VTubers.
Are you trying to say VTubers are infertile?
That's fucked up.
You said that.
Um...
Let's see.
What was I?
Psychoz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Here's a tip for the ear medicine.
Get a cute girl and treats to distract dad and it'll be easy peasy.
Oh my god.
So like...
Okay.
So I was talking about how like... Okay.
So he hated the male nurse at the vet.
But like it was so funny because like the male nurse brought like a jar of treats and then he was fine.
He was so fucking excited.
And um... And then like obviously he was like... So the male nurse was trying to teach me how to do the medicine thing.
And then he put down the jar of treats.
And the thing is he forgot to put a cover.
And then...
And then dad just bolted to the... Because we were on the...
He was on the table.
He was on the fucking table.
Like the pet examination table.
And he bolted into the jar of treats and stuck his head in there.
He was like...
And I was like I'm so sorry.
I couldn't grab him in time.
Because like he let go of him.
So then I was supposed to grab him after he let go of him.
Because he had to let go and put down his jar of treats.
And then he just bolted to the jar of treats and stuck his entire head into the jar.
And like he sees the moment in no shit.
I know he's just incredibly food motivated.
That's what like the thing is.
I don't know if it's like a wiener dog thing.
I don't know if it's like a dachshund thing.
But like I feel like every wiener dog I've owned is incredibly food motivated.
They just love food.
They don't care.
They don't care if they've been fed or not.
They just really fucking love food.
So yeah.
So I was like No!
Stop!
I'm sorry!
I'm like I'm so sorry!
That's just dogs in general.
Alright.
Let's see.
Lolly thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Heart the size of a peppercorn.
Lungs corroded.
Intestines and corroded.
Three kidney stones.
Fluid in the brain.
One testy swollen and black as a coal.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Poor guy.
That's like insane.
Lolly thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's why you don't keep the bloodline pure.
That is why we don't do that anymore.
Like we don't marry.
Also like it's really fucked up to marry your fucking sibling or relatives or whatever.
Morally it's also incredibly fucked up.
But now we have the science to tell you why it's fucked up too.
The bloodline was too pure.
Like now we have both reasons why you shouldn't do that.
Um Let's see.
Um.
Chyna thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't believe Doki is the bay harbor butcher.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh Turtles thank you for the super chat.
Remember that you're not a fish.
The hicks should go away.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Cypher thank you for the super chat.
Let's see.
Um.
Oh yeah.
By the way.
So like you guys didn't know.
Um.
I'm gonna be doing an apex tournament.
This Saturday.
The Sorry.
The Riksa 2.0 Apex Invitational.
I was gonna invite other VTuber.
I was actually the very last captain spot.
Um.
I was the very last captain slot.
Because like when I asked like.
When I asked like.
Um.
I asked somebody if they're doing it.
And then they were like Oh yeah.
Like I got invited.
Cause I was trying to.
Cause I had to find teammates.
I had three days to find teammates.
Cause I got the captain slot.
Um.
I got the captain slot literally on Thursday.
Wednesday I think.
I got.
I I got.
I asked about if there was still slots for captains.
And I got it on Wednesday.
And I had to find teammates on that Friday.
Like my deadline for teammates was Friday.
And I was like the last captain basically.
I think I was like one of the last captains.
And I was like asking somebody.
I was like oh yeah like.
Um.
Are you doing it?
And they're like oh yeah.
I'm one of the captains.
I'm.
Like I got the captain slot like a month ago.
And I was like A MONTH AGO?
I was like That's a fucking month ago.
So.
Um.
I was gonna ask like.
I didn't know how competitive this was.
So like.
When I got into the server.
Um.
Uh.
Cause I was like okay what is like the competition like?
And then I saw like pro players.
So I was like So cause like.
Cause so I was like okay.
I don't wanna get destroyed.
I don't.
I saw like literally some teams.
had like pros in them.
And then like it was like I had full pros or something.
Or like half pros.
Like it was like two pros and everything.
Or like no pros.
And I was like okay.
There's some.
There's some like actual pro players in here.
Like actual going to like Japan for LAN pro.
So I was like alright.
I guess.
I guess I gotta get pros too.
Cause I don't wanna get absolutely destroyed.
Like.
So.
So I was like.
So I got.
I got effect.
The reason why.
Okay it was originally.
Okay the team was originally.
Um.
The team.
And also like I haven't played Apex in a while too.
So I was like Ah shit.
Like a lot of the people that were in the tournament.
They play Apex regularly.
Like every fucking day.
And I've been like whoa.
Like I've not been consistent.
So it was gonna be effect.
And gen burden.
Um.
So originally.
I was gonna be effect and gen burden.
Um.
Because like uh.
Gen burden has wanted to play with me again.
And I was like Oh I have this tournament invite.
And then he almost joined.
But because it was at.
But when we realized what time it is.
It would be 5 in the morning for him in Australia.
So I was like Ah shit.
Like.
He's like yeah I can't do 5 in the morning.
He's like I'm sorry I'm in Australia right now.
I can't do.
I can't do 5 in the morning.
So effect was like oh yes we can get unlucky.
Um.
Cause he's down to play.
So I was like yeah alright.
Let's grab fucking half of alliance into my roster.
Like Let's just.
Let's just grab half of alliance.
Let's go.
Or like two thirds.
Two thirds of alliance.
We're just missing Hakkas.
We're literally just missing Hakkas.
Um.
So for those who don't know.
For those who don't know.
Alliance They are They are.
They won Esports.
They won the Apex World Cup.
And effect was the MVP of the entire World Cup.
So Um.
So basically.
You know They're really fucking good.
Like They really They literally won Um.
The World Cup for Apex.
So.
And then they were third in the last Man.
Um.
So the reason why I asked effect is that Effect and I We were originally gonna do a Tournament together.
Before I came back here as Doki.
And like effect Actually told me that he really enjoyed my streams.
And um.
He really enjoyed My streams.
And like I think like he likes watching me.
And like he was like I really wanted to play with you In the future again.
So he was like Before then.
Before I came back.
Like he was like Super hyped about playing with me.
Cause he was Like oh my god I love your streams.
And like I'm so Happy that.
Um.
I'm so happy To play with you.
And so like I never had a chance to invite him again.
No.
Okay.
He's basically a dragoon.
This is a funny story.
It's so funny.
Um.
Like I don't remember This was like.
I saw him Liked one of my tweets.
Um.
While he was in the Middle of the World Cup Apex World Cup Game.
Cause I like.
I was like.
Oh shit.
In fact he liked one of my tweets.
And then I like.
I was like wait.
Isn't he Like playing right now?
And then I looked up.
I like looked up On Twitch.
And I literally See him fucking playing Like.
He's like Playing Apex.
In the Fucking land.
Isn't he playing in land Right now.
At like Fucking World Cup in Saudi Arabia Like I was like I like Swapped.
I looked up on Twitch And I literally see him playing.
Like.
So he He like fucking I don't know.
Like I don't know if it was like An intermission or like You know.
He was like waiting for something To happen.
He was waiting For something to happen in his game.
And he got on Twitter and fucking liked One of my tweets.
Um.
So like He got his Priorities straight.
So that's why I was like Oh hey do you want to.
Like you know We were meant to.
We were supposed to play a tournament Like all those months ago.
And we couldn't.
So do you want to join me in this tournament?
So that's why I asked him.
Cause I was like Well I need a pro player anyways.
So like cause like You know.
Almost like half the teams Were basically like pro player teams.
Like.
So I was like half the teams were basically Like pro player teams.
So.
So I was like You know.
I'll grab effect Since like I want to play with him anyway.
Like I Um.
We were supposed to.
But then we never did.
And then that was the chance to do it.
And then.
And then you know.
I was like Ah who did get third.
And You know.
I asked Jen too.
Because Jen Also like reached out to me.
And was Like oh man.
Like we should play again Sometime.
And then.
But there was never like An opportunity.
He was originally Gonna be in my hide and seek team.
When we Did that hide and seek tournament.
Um.
But then like he.
Like he Literally.
He was like.
He literally got asked.
Like um.
I was like An hour late of asking him.
And he was like Fuck.
Like if you asked an hour earlier.
Well like I could have joined your team.
And So like.
This was like another opportunity.
So I was like.
Oh yeah.
Like um.
Like might as well ask him.
Cause like.
You know.
He wanted to play Again in the future.
But then obviously Time zones didn't line up.
So we weren't able to.
And then.
So I was like.
Ah shit.
Who did I get A third.
And then I asked Effect.
Cause like.
Literally I had to finalize Teams by Friday.
So I had to.
I had to Finalize teams by Friday.
And I was like.
Who the fuck do I Ask.
So then Effect was like.
Oh I could Grab Unlucky.
Like cause they're in Japan.
Apparently.
Uh.
They're in Japan right now.
Together.
Doing something for alliance.
And we're like.
Yeah I'll grab.
I'll grab Unlucky.
He's totally down.
So I was like.
Yeah alright.
Fuck it.
Let's go.
Two thirds of alliance.
Like it's not.
People were like.
What the fuck.
And then when I.
Cause we had to report our teams.
And everybody.
Like.
A lot of people.
When they saw my team.
They're like.
What the fuck.
Cause they're like.
I was.
What the fuck.
That's not fair.
And I'm like.
What do you mean.
I was like.
You can't do that to me.
Other teams also have Pro players.
You can't.
I just wanna chill.
I.
I don't wanna have a terrible time too.
Like.
Your pro player is different.
Doki.
There were other pro players too.
Look.
Uh.
I also like wanna chill too.
I don't wanna get like absolutely destroyed as well.
Like I'm like a huge nerf.
I haven't played this game in so long.
I'm literally the debuff right now.
I didn't even get Hawkus.
Hawkus is literally the IGL of alliance.
None of us are IGLs.
I might have two controller players.
But like.
We don't have an IGL.
I have two roller players.
Like.
I'm literally the sandbag.
Yeah.
That's all.
I'm literally the sandbag of the team.
Uh.
Anyway.
Um.
So.
Yeah.
That's how the team came to be.
Um.
And.
Your team is already broken.
Some teams have fucking IGLs.
Some of the pro player teams have an actual IGL.
We don't have an IGL.
Like.
Anyway.
So.
That's how.
Okay.
So.
Because I haven't played.
And how many.
Okay.
Look.
It might be two controller players.
But they nerfed controller guys.
They nerfed controller guys.
Like.
It's not that strong.
Um.
I have the best soldier.
They only have commanders.
Um.
Hey.
Guys.
Okay.
So.
Yeah.
That's how.
Basically.
And I'm.
Okay.
Because.
Like.
I realize.
Oh shit.
Like.
You know.
It's not as.
The teams aren't as intense as Twitch Rivals.
Cause Twitch Rivals it's like literally all pros.
Uh.
It's literally all pros.
And like.
Uh.
So it's not as hard as Twitch Rivals.
So I was like.
Oh shit.
There's like regular players like me.
So that means there's a chance that I can actually like.
You know.
Have an actual 1v1.
Instead of playing against full pros.
Because in Twitch Rivals I'm always playing against pro players.
So it's so fucking scary.
Like.
It's so fucking scary.
So.
Um.
So I was like.
Oh yeah.
Like.
This time.
You know.
There's a chance to survive.
Like.
So I was like.
Okay.
I should actually practice Apex.
So the past couple of days.
The past couple of days.
Um.
I've been playing Apex.
And I.
I don't.
Okay.
So like.
At one point.
Last night.
I was playing Apex at like 4 in the morning.
But like.
Yesterday night.
Yeah.
I was playing Apex at 4 in the morning.
And I don't know if that's like.
I don't know if like.
It's an Apex thing.
Or like.
If.
It's an Apex thing.
Or it's been like.
Or if like.
People are just leveling up.
They're leveling up accounts to sell.
Because.
I.
I like.
Bumped it.
I had like.
Bots on my team.
Like.
Actual Bots.
I've never had that before.
Like.
I'd never played.
I haven't played Apex at extremely.
DJ night.
But like.
I got bots on my team.
And like.
Bots on enemy teams too.
So like.
It's very easy to spot.
Because.
Um.
They would have no badges.
And they will pick.
Lifeline.
Bloodhound.
Or Bangalore.
And like.
But I don't know if it's like.
Apex that's doing it.
Or like.
I don't know if the game is doing it.
Or.
Um.
Or like.
If it's other people trying to level up their account.
Like.
Level up accounts to sell.
I can't tell.
But.
Before then.
I.
When I used like.
You know like.
Maybe like.
Two years ago.
Or a year ago.
A year ago.
That would never happen at four in the morning.
So I was so confused.
And it's like every game.
It's every fucking game.
That's the thing.
It's every game.
And they would like.
They would just like.
They all land.
And you would see so many of them.
I had like games where like.
I had games where my entire team were bots.
Like.
They were all bots.
And then they all.
And then you see other bots also landing.
Cause they don't.
They don't do.
Be jump master.
They're not jump master.
They're literally like just.
You know.
They just land there.
I'm like.
What the fuck?
Like.
Just be like.
What?
And then when they die.
They just insta dc.
They insta dc when they're dead.
So I.
It was so confusing.
I couldn't tell.
I couldn't tell if it came from the game itself.
Like.
You know how like Fortnite adds bots to the game.
So I couldn't tell if it's Apex adding bots to the servers.
Or if it's like.
Or if it's like people trying to farm.
Farm like.
Farm accounts.
I can't couldn't tell.
I couldn't.
Yeah.
I just couldn't tell.
They don't do anything.
So it's been like.
It was fucking wild.
I was so frustrated too.
I was so frustrated cause I wanted like a real player on my team.
I just wanted a real player.
Lolly thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Remember when you were in beta and thought the devs were bots.
Yeah.
That's the thing.
I can't tell.
I can't tell what's real anymore.
I can't tell what's real and what's fake anymore.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Magic thank you for the super chat.
Archaeologist asked me something.
This question very often.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gamer and ghost.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Also I thought this was really funny.
I want to do this to somebody.
I saw this.
I saw this video and I really I really wanted I really wanted to pull this off.
It's a good video.
I just want to pull this off on somebody.
By the way, I saw somebody wearing an actual ninja hoodie in public.
I can't believe they're real.
I saw like... I was walking I was walking in Dokey Amber Doge and then literally I got out of the lobby and then somebody had a ninja hoodie.
And the blue one too.
The actual blue ninja hoodie.
And they exist.
And I don't think it was... I think he was a real fan.
It was not ironic.
It was like a legitimate blue ninja hoodie.
And I was like, holy shit you're real.
You're actually real.
Like...
It was...
Oh my god.
You can get this at Walmart?
Oh my guys.
You can... Oh my god.
You can buy this at Walmart.
Oh my god.
Like...
I was so surprised.
I was like, holy shit they're...
These fans are real people.
And they wore that...
The fact that they wore this in public was what surprised me the most.
I saw some guy wear this hoodie in public.
Like I was...
I was... I just...
I couldn't believe it.
I...
It like...
It like freaked me out cause I was like you're real.
You're a real person.
He was...
He was a university student.
Cause he was carrying that backpack to go to university.
Like...
He was wearing a university hoodie.
I won't say what university it was.
But he was wearing a university ho...
Like no sorry.
He was wearing a university backpack.
He was wearing a university backpack and he had a ninja hoodie on.
And I was like you're real.
You're...
You're fucking real.
You're real.
Eat, sleep, fortnight, repeat.
Anyway.
Sudo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Been on a transformer kick lately and got me curious.
If you were a transformer, what would you want your alt mode to be?
A vehicle or an animal?
I wanna be a fucking animal.
I feel like Beast Wars are so fucking sick honestly.
Not... What's the right guy?
Rattrap?
No.
Other than Rattrap because he has like his fucking brain exposed.
All the other Beast Wars transformers are so fucking sick.
Yeah.
Rattrap's a...
Don't... Don't try to argue with me.
We all know Rattrap is fucking ugly.
Um...
Other than Rattrap they all look really fucking sick.
Um... You take that back!
We all know it's true.
Don't fucking deny it.
Um...
Let's see.
Ghost Rider, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Let the Doki demonetization fun begin.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um... Playmaker, thank you for the super chat.
Water with no soap?
What kind of cleaning service is this?
Look.
Look, you... They paid me five thousand dollars to clean three fucking bodies.
You know what you were getting at that point.
Five K for three bodies?
Like, come on.
Like, that is like... You're a dealer.
I know you make more than five thousand dollars.
Um...
That's the Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He was one of the kids at the Ninja DJ set.
He has to wear that backpack or as penance for not moving.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh...
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba Uh...
Uh... Oh my god, we didn't get Eurobeat!
Someone said they wanted Eurobeat in the Akasupa.
Sorry, Anton.
Are you still here, Anton?
Do you want that Disney Eurobeat?
Okay, Eurobeat.
We're not cleaning anymore.
But let's get some movement in there.
Guys, this is where we're actually testing this.
Wait, under the sea?
Disney Eurobeat?
What does that sound like?
Oh my god.
Is that even good?
Uh...
It's always greener when somebody else is late.
Dream about going up there.
But that is a big mistake.
Look at the world behind you.
On the ocean floor.
It's Disney Eurobeat!
It's...
It's... It's... It's...
Under the sea.
I think it's better down where it's wetter.
Take it from me.
Work all day.
Up in the sun they stay away.
So don't be floating under the sea.
Okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But... Wait, is Anton even here?
No!
Didn't fully commit to the stream.
I'm joking.
Anton...
All right.
If anybody see Anton...
Anton later, tell them I played Eurobeat at the end.
No!
They're gone!
Tell them we did it.
I did read their account!
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Transmetal Rattrap was one of the coolest designs ever.
I will not stand with this slander.
Okay, let me see what that looks like.
What is that?
What does Transmetal Rattrap look like?
The fuck?
Oh, he's still ugly.
It's just...
He's just... Bro, his brain's orange.
Like, what?
A different color brain does not mean...
Um...
It's not mean it's better.
Stop being a fool.
But the wheels!
His brain is orange!
Like, what?
What do you want me to say?
His brain is still fucking exposed and or...
Now it's orange!
Okay, but what animal almost specifically?
I feel like the fanartists will really appreciate it.
They give us super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know.
Surprise me.
There's a lot of like... Other than Rattrap, a lot of designs are really cool.
I know like everybody was fucking in love with Arachnid.
Was it Arachnid?
Beast Wars?
Was that her?
Yeah.
Everybody loved Arachnid.
Um, I don't know why.
Okay, we all know why.
Black Arachnia.
We all know why.
Oh, yeah.
Let's see...
Uh, Darkblade, they give us super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do you think that girl is okay?
I think she might need a band-aid.
They give us super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh...
I'm gonna read five more super chats and then I'm gonna call it here, guys.
And then I'm gonna call it here.
I'm scrolling to see... I lost count, guys.
I lost track of where I was in my super chats.
Gia, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
If Doki gets a pet pig in the future, we know what happened.
What?
Pigs can be cute?
Getting a pet pig does not mean, like, a murder was committed, guys.
Like, it might be very poor timing, you know?
If I get a pet pig right after...
right after... Oh my god, there's a Garfield Nendoroid.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
I was scrolling through.
I can multicast, guys.
Oh my god.
Okay, if you... guys, if you're a true dragoon, you will grab a... you will grab a Garfield Nendoroid next to the Doki Bird Nendoroid, and then we can hold hands.
Oh my god, it's so...
Oh my god.
You know what would be cooler?
You swap the heads.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
I wanna be Garfield.
Swap my head with Garfield.
Um, anyway.
Anyway, as I was saying, as I was saying, uh, um...
If I have get a pet pig right after this stream, it does not mean that I committed a murder.
I just think pigs are really cute.
And if my pig seems...
If my pig seems really, really happy, and like, you're like, wow, Doki, where did you keep the food?
And I never show you guys where I keep the food.
It is because, like, it's just too much work to get the food, okay guys?
It's just way too much work.
Um, I have it locked up in a cupboard because I don't want him to, like... I don't want the pig to...
I don't want... It's as if I have a pig right now.
That's crazy talk.
That's so crazy.
I'm saying as if I already have the pig.
But...
Uh...
Um, anyway.
Let's see.
Charco, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The current generation gets the bootleg version of our things.
Don't believe me?
Halo, Lord of the Rings, Call of Duty, Spongebob, Pokemon, etc.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I just think it's weird that instead of making new shows, they just, um...
They literally just like, you know, reboot our show... the shows that we used to watch.
Or like, they just add more episodes to it and bring it back.
I just feel it's weird because some of the voice actors and actresses are super fucking old.
Like how people are like, bring back Gravity Falls.
Like, I know like a lot of people want to bring back Gravity Falls.
But like, oh my...
Like, you know what I'm really worried about?
So you know like, the guy that does the voice acts for it in Gravity Falls?
Um, you know, it's the drum...
Sorry, it's J.K.
Simmons.
And you know how old J.K.
Simmons is?
He's like, he's 70 years old now.
Like...
He's...
He's 70 years old now.
And like...
It's a little worrisome.
It just wouldn't be the same.
I feel like Gravity Falls ended perfectly as well.
Um...
It ended perfectly.
And I don't think you should... Like, I know people are desperate because it was a really good show, but I just think that like...
Sorry, 69.
Nice.
I just think like...
I'm just worried if you bring it back, it's just not gonna be the same.
He's been in Omni-Man?
Yeah, but like, you couldn't tell he's...
They didn't make him do a lot of voice acting in Omni-Man.
You couldn't tell that the newest season, he did not voice acted as much as he did in the first season.
Like...
He did not get a lot of screen time.
And when he did, it felt less...
Less like season one.
I don't know.
That's how I felt when I watched it.
When I watched it, I was like... I felt like his voice acting as Omni-Man for the newest season definitely was like not as good as the first season.
Like it was... It just felt like a little bit like...
It felt... It just didn't feel the same.
Yeah.
It just didn't feel the same.
Um...
LordPancake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Honestly, the kids will be better served by just looking up the old media instead of going for the remix.
At this point, they have decades of good content to explore, depending on... Yeah.
Yeah, I agree with that too.
It's like how people still watch... I mean, I can understand being like Tom and Jerry gets rebooted every once in a while.
But also, Tom and Jerry don't fucking talk.
Like...
Oh, you can see it.
In some cases, Tom and Jerry do not talk at all.
So like it's easy to reboot them.
And then we have like Bugs Bunny and stuff.
We can get like impersonator...
like impressionist to do that voice acting and stuff.
But then it's also cause like Bugs Bunny has like a long history of like people... of people like of like a long history of impressionist and stuff.
But then for like some of these shows, you can't really get impressionator... impressions because like they're... they're the act... because they get like famous actors and actresses that legitimately just do their own voice.
Like...
Like what's her name?
Kristen Shaw for Mabel?
That's literally her voice.
Like you can't get like an impressionist for her.
Like...
Like a lot of the... it's just their fucking voice.
So I'm just like I don't think you can have like an actual impressionist to do Kristen Shaw's voice because it's literally just her voice when she's talking.
It's a really good voice.
It's a very unique voice.
But yeah.
Um...
Uh... I just think you super chat.
Thank you.
Um... Oh my god.
Look, my pig made a friend.
Um... It's just in time for Halloween.
Uh...
Sandwich, welcome to Tomato Forum.
Welcome.
Chris Pat has insane range.
Just look at Mari.
And Jack Black too.
I can't believe people now don't like Jack Black because it took... it took people like 30 plus years to realize Jack Black has been playing Jack Black this entire time.
But people didn't care because everybody thought Jack Black was just so fucking cool.
But then it...
He's literally been playing himself for like 30 plus years.
But nobody cared until now.
Because of... He did two really bad movies.
Two really bad movies.
You know, not just the Minecraft.
Until the...
It was until...
What was it called?
What was it?
Until the...
Everybody forgot about that movie already.
Borderlands.
Yeah.
I like how everybody was like, it was until Minecraft.
I'm like, wow.
We all fucking deleted Borderlands out of our minds.
It's never...
It hasn't even been like three, two months yet.
And we all like...
We all just forgot about Borderlands.
And Kung Fu Panda 4 too.
And Kung Fu Panda 4.
Kung Fu Panda 4 was pretty bad.
Bro, he...
He's been playing like... He's been fucking playing Jack Black since 2000 and...
Since the 2000s.
Not even 2000s to 9.
He 1990s.
It was literally all his like really good movies are just him playing himself.
Um...
He was like the... He was like the counter Chris Pratt.
Like, Chris Pratt would play himself, but he's sort of like...
He's...
I don't know what the fuck happened.
Like...
Oh, he joined like...
I was gonna say... He became like incredibly weird.
I was gonna say.
Didn't he join... Like he joined like a specific church.
And then he left his wife and his kid.
And then people were like mad about it.
And that's how like everybody um...
Everybody got like really weird about him.
Um... He basically left his wife and his other child.
Uh... For this other wife.
Um...
For the other lady.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot.
That's crazy.
Wait, he married her?
Probably Scientology.
No, it's not Sci...
I don't remember if it was Sci... I don't think it's Scientology.
Is it Scientology?
I feel like we could... Oh my god.
I found a...
I saw a Scientology church.
I thought I saw... I found...
I didn't realize they exist in Canada.
But like... You know, I thought it was like an American thing.
But...
But like...
But like... Literally, when I was taking... I was... I don't know where I was going.
But I was taking an Uber to somewhere.
And I was like, what the fuck?
There's a Scientology church here?
I was like, they exist in Canada?
Like...
I was like, oh my god.
They fucking breached Canadian borders?
Like...
I was so surprised.
I was not...
Not expecting the Scientologist to be here.
Anyway...
Um...
But yeah.
And then like, that's when it got really weird.
Because he left his...
Like...
He left his wife and son for the other lady.
And then things went down.
Because he used to be a really cool guy.
Like everybody liked him in the Lego movie.
And everybody liked him in Parks and Rec.
And everything.
And then like, for some reason he started being fucking weird.
Like he started...
He just started being really weird.
And people were like, what the fuck?
Like...
What the fuck happened?
Like he just fell off.
Because he was such a cool guy when he used to be in Parks... I loved him in Parks and Rec.
Um... That was like his big big break too.
And then he started being fucking weird.
And now Jack Black is now slowly heading there.
I liked how... Okay.
I think the funniest... Okay, not funny.
But everybody is saying that Kevin Hart is like a studio plant.
I was just like, holy fuck.
Like, you guys see that?
Everyone was like, Kevin Hart was a plant.
By Hollywood.
People fucking pushed him so hard.
Because of Hollywood.
Um...
He can't even grow above his height.
Do you guys see that?
People think he's like some studio...
Some Hollywood plant that was not supposed to be popular.
Um...
If he is, he didn't grow enough.
I was so surprised.
I was like, no wonder he's every...
Cause like, okay.
I can understand why.
Because every fucking comedy movie he's been in in the last ten years fucking sucked.
But they keep casting him.
Like, I...
I don't understand.
Like...
It's fucking...
Comedy movies are so fucking bad.
But he still gets casted.
Like...
It would be fun.
He has good voice acting.
I can say that his voice acting is actually really good.
I mean, he plays... It's literally his own voice.
He has a very good voice for voice acting.
Because it's so unique.
Um...
I liked his voice acting in Captain Underpants, the animated movie.
But there's been like... But his comedy... But his comedy IRL movies...
Sucked.
I didn't like it.
I didn't like some of the movies he... Like, I was trying to... I was trying to get... Like, check him out.
Like, check out his stuff in, like, movies and stuff.
But I just didn't.
To be fair, Will Ferrell's fucking movies suck too.
Like, for a while too, to be honest.
They always hit that area where it's like...
Where it's like... It's like a weird place where they don't even, like, have really good movies.
They gave them both really...
Yeah, it's like...
I feel like comedy movies are so hard to, like, make... make it good.
Because it has to have really good writing.
Um... It has to have really, really good, uh...
writing.
Um...
But, like... Oh my gosh.
Just... It's just...
I don't know.
I feel like the only movie I liked from Kevin Hart.
Was, like, Jumanji.
I actually... I actually low-key liked Jumanji.
Like...
The... The... The first Jumanji movie.
Like, it's a Jumanji movie that shouldn't have been a Jumanji movie.
I feel like if it wasn't... If it was its own thing...
If it wasn't its own thing, it... I feel like it could have succeeded without having to... Without having to... Uh...
What's the... What's the word called?
Banking off of nostalgia factor?
With Jumanji.
I enjoyed it.
I enjoyed Jumanji.
Uh... But I feel like it didn't have to be...
It didn't have to be called Jumanji.
Uh...
Yeah, if it didn't have that tag, nobody would watch it.
Yeah.
It just had, like, nothing related to the... I just felt like it had nothing really related to the first movie.
Uh...
Alright.
Let's see.
Where was... Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
I'll do one more Super Chat, guys.
I know I said five.
I don't know how many I read.
But, like, uh... I know I said five.
So...
We'll just do one more.
There's Super Pets?
He was in Super Pets?
What the fuck is Super Pets?
DC League of Super Pets.
There was a movie about the pets of superheroes?
Like, why the fuck have I never heard of... Oh...
It must have been bad.
Oh, 56% on Metacrit...
Credit.
I never heard about this movie.
Oh, Kevin Hart was... What the fuck was Kevin Hart as?
Oh!
The Rock!
Okay, Rock was in here.
Okay.
No wonder they were together.
What the fuck was Kevin Hart as Ace?
He later becomes Batman's pet dog?
Wait!
Batman's pet dog isn't a fucking boxer?
What?
I thought Batman's pet dog was like...
He was like...
Wait, he was a boxer?
Batman's pet dog.
That's not a...
That's not a boxer?
No, he does.
What the fuck is that dog breed?
He says a puppy.
It doesn't even... Oh, he is!
Oh my god, I didn't realize.
Oh my god, it is.
Cause, like, what I know about, like, Batman...
Yeah, they all apparently have, like, pets or whatever.
This is what I remember.
Um, yeah, I thought he was like a Doberman.
I didn't realize, like, he was actually supposed to be a boxer.
Is this how I remember him?
How I remember...
Uh, sorry, let's get this Garfield out of here.
This is how I remember him.
And then I know, like, Crypto the super dog.
I know, like, they all have, like, pets and stuff because it's, like, marketing.
Uh...
Yeah, Wonder Woman has a kangaroo.
Okay, superhero.
I don't fucking know.
Oh, yeah, she, like, saved it or something.
So, like, they have, like, uh, they have... Who's the cow?
Is that Green Lantern, right?
Who owns the cow?
Who owns the fucking cow?
Wait, who the fuck is the cow?
Yeah!
There's a cow in here.
Is it Batman?
Oh, yeah, there's a squirrel.
There's...
Oh, Green Lantern's squirrel.
The Superman... Okay, I said backdrop.
They were joined once more.
Back... No, it's Batman!
There's a Batcow?
As a character created for Batcow so much they incorporated her into the new Batman...
Batcow became something of a meme when it was time to round up.
Oh, my God!
There's a fucking... Oh, shit!
Harley Quinn owns a fucking dachshund!
That's lucky, right?
What the fuck is this picture?
Okay, I did not realize Batcow was a thing.
There's this.
I'll show you guys Batcow.
There's Bat... I hope my butt doesn't get flagged.
That's not blood, it's Kool-Aid.
There we go.
Look,
see it?
There's a fucking...
It's a fucking cow!
Alright, guys, it's just... guys, it's not.
It's red paint, guys.
Please don't flag my... Please don't flag my fucking video.
I didn't know that.
Oh, there it is.
There's Wonder Woman with a kangaroo.
Why the fuck does she have a kangaroo?
Technically the oldest super pet.
Jumpa was the high jumping kangaroo mount of young Diana.
Oh, she's like her horse!
Cause she's special!
There's a fucking monkey?!
There's...
There's super monkey?!
Guys, there's fucking super monkey.
There's...
There's super monkey.
Oh my god!
Super Bones owns a fucking monkey!
Alright.
This is what it looks like.
Super boy.
Look at that!
That's interesting.
That's actually really interesting.
Okay, I got off track.
Alright, guys, we're gonna call it here.
It was nice to just chat again.
Hey, everybody!
I'm gonna call it here.
I hope you guys had a great time hanging out with me today.
As always, everybody stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stood up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!